So, meine Damen und Herren, da ist es das Chaos Radio am letzten Mittwoch im Monat auf Fritz, ein bisschen mächtigere Musik gerade noch mal gestartet, damit die Aufmerksamkeitsphase auch ein bisschen nach oben ausschlägt. Im Studio natürlich wie immer vom Chaos Computer Club, jemand und zwar in diesem Fall Tim Pritlove mal wieder, endlich mal.
Pritlove heißt das.
Seit wann heißt das denn schon wieder Pritlove? Das überlegst du dir auch alle zwei Wochen anders.
Das stimmt überhaupt nicht.
Das hat noch nie Pritlove geheißen. Immer dann, wenn ich dich abends nach 1 Uhr anrufe, dann sagst du, es ist egal, wenn du mich schnellst. Hauptsache der Vorname kommt korrekt drüber.
Da hast du natürlich recht.
Ja und mein Name ist Max von Malodki. Nicht zu vergessen, wir haben einen stetigen und ständigen Gast für den heutigen Abend bis 1 Uhr beim Chaosradio geladen. Und zwar Jörg Cantel, der zum Thema Wichtiges beitragen wird. Hallo Jörg.
Hallo und guten Abend euch allen da draußen.
Es wird nämlich gehen heute Abend um Weblogs. Und wir haben natürlich gewusst, dass dieses Thema ein bisschen spezieller ist, dass man nicht sofort unbedingt 100%ig weiß, worum es da geht. Deswegen wird es gleich eine kleine Einführung geben. Und wir werden einfach mal mit euch darüber reden, was Weblogs sind. Und vielleicht habt ihr ja auch schon mal das eine oder andere darüber erfahren. Wenn ihr es uns also leichter machen wollt und wir euch nicht alles erklären sollen, dann könnt ihr jetzt schon mal anrufen 031 70 97 1 1 0 im Blumen. Wenn ihr was von Weblogs versteht, selber eins schreibt, schon mal eins gelesen habt oder so ungefähr wisst, was es ist, dann meldet euch bei uns und ruft an. 031 70 97 1 1 und die 0. Bis dahin gibt es ein bisschen Mucke. Wir schließen uns gerade noch ein bisschen an und machen die Rechner klar. Deswegen was, was ich mitgebracht hab von Missy Elliott. Ihr hört das Chaosradio auf Fritz, letzter Mittwoch im Monat mit dem Chaos Computer Club und ihr hört, wir basteln hier noch rum. Das ist klar, das ist jedes Mal so. Wenn man einem Geek oder einem Nerd noch mehr Zeit gibt, um noch mehr Geräte anzuschließen, dann wird er noch mehr Geräte anschließen. Das ist bei Tim, der heute unbedingt Pritt Love genannt werden soll, auch schon wieder so.
Verflucht noch eins.
Was hast du denn immer alles dabei? Und vor allen Dingen jedes Mal ein neues Gerät.
Du kennst doch diese Internetunterversorgungssituation hier, da muss man ja irgendwas gegen tun. Weil ich mir nix diesem Windows-Computer rumklicken, deswegen versuche ich hier mein Gerät in Betrieb zu nehmen.
Also Berlin und Mannenburg, wir machen es uns gerade noch ein bisschen gemütlich, möchten natürlich mit euch reden am heutigen Abend. Thema haben wir uns, ist ein Wunschthema für dieses Jahr, rausgesucht, bevor es sich vielleicht nicht mehr gibt und wir nicht mehr drüber reden können, nämlich das Thema Webblogs. Es ist momentan tatsächlich ein Hype, wer es noch nicht gehört hat, listen close, weil wir werden heute Abend drüber reden und es könnte der Trend sein, der euch auch erfasst, oder es könnte irgendwann schon wieder tot sein. Als Gäste im Studio sind natürlich wir alle selber, weil wir reden ja auch gerne alle selber über dieses Thema, deswegen haben wir uns auch selbst heute dafür ausgesucht. Der Tim, dann der Jörg vom Schockwellenreiter.
Namen noch mal.
Sorry, das wird sein Einsatz für den ganzen Abend.
Ich werd dich noch 18 Mal begrüßen heute Abend.
Und Max von Wallocki, vom verdammt guten Kuchen. Wie bist du eigentlich auf die Domänen gekommen?
Ich hab mir mein kleines Webblog damals eingerichtet und dachte mir, es muss irgendwas sein, was ein bisschen anders klingt und was nicht irgendwie das Wort Trendy oder Block oder so im Namen hat. Deswegen dachte ich, ich nehme etwas ganz Bescheuertes und das bitte in einem Wort, was eigentlich zu lang ist. Ich fand, es musste so ein bisschen fies sein. Deswegen verdammtguterkuchen.de habe ich ausgesucht.
Hervorragend.
Außerdem ist es ein Zitat aus Twin Peaks.
Ach so.
Weil der Hauptdarsteller sagt an einer Stelle nämlich, also er redet über Leichen und redet über Leichenteile und sagt dann immer so Stiche im unteren Rektum. Der Kopf war vollkommen stranguliert. Übrigens, ich bin da auf der Autobahn bei so einem Laden vorbeigegommen. Verdammtguterkuchen. Das sagt er halt einfach so instiktiergerät für seine...
Ist das nicht der mit den Donuts irgendwie, diese Donut?
Nee, der ist auch, der ist Kuchen.
Generell Kuchen.
Also generell Süßigkeiten.
Das sagt ja schon wieder einiges aus, aber nicht auch über dieses Wesen, nämlich dass das eigentlich doch eine recht persönliche Angelegenheit ist, teilweise vielleicht auch eine private Angelegenheit, finde ich so. Das ist auch eigentlich meine eigene Erfahrung gewesen. Die Sendung ist ja auch nicht als Webblogs Sendung angekündigt worden, sondern das Wort, das wir verwendet haben, ist so die Eindeutung eines, ja eines beliebten Begriffes, eben in dieser Webblog Szene, die Blogosphäre oder eben auf Englisch The Blogosphere. Das ist so ein Begriff, der sich herausgebildet hat. Ich weiß nicht, wie lange der schon kreist.
Das ist relativ neu erst. Irgendwie so seit einem Jahr, schätze ich mal, kamen größere Diskussionen über Community-Bildung, Community in Webblogs auf. Und dann tauchte auch dieser Begriff Blogosphäre auf. Erst mal richtig gehört, also ich selber richtig zur Kenntnis genommen, habe ich ihn auf dieser Blogtalk-Konferenz in Wien im Mai dieses Jahres. Er existierte aber schon vorher, ist nur immer an mir vorbeigerutscht. Das ist eine oder andere raus, dann war es weg.
Hat sich aber, glaube ich, mittlerweile ganz gut manifestiert. Ist eigentlich auch eine schöne Umschreibung, weil es eigentlich schon eine erkennbare Subkultur gibt im Internet, die sich im Wesentlichen durch das persönliche Schreiben auszeichnet und natürlich auch das Lesen desselben, so ein Hin und Her von Kleinartikeln. Technisch ist ja ein Webblog einmal nichts anderes als eine regelmäßig gefüllte Webseite mit mehr oder weniger langen Informationsschnipseln, die persönlicher oder komplett unpersönlicher Natur sein können. Der persönliche Aspekt ist halt, dass es in der Regel immer einer ist, der schreibt. Auch da gibt es Ausnahmen, aber sehr häufig ist ein Webblog eben ein Mannunternehmen oder ein Frauunternehmen. Und so richtig neu ist das auch nicht. Die Kultur des persönlichen Schreibens gibt es auch im Internet eigentlich von Anfang an. Ich habe das seinerzeit wahrgenommen, als die McIntosh-Szene sich so ans Internet... Ich brauche mal ein bisschen Musik, ne?
Ja, natürlich, natürlich. Ich kann dafür sorgen.
Nee, ich sorge mal dafür. Kannst du mich jetzt mal...
Also, du kannst nur dafür sorgen, wenn ich dafür sorge, nur damit wir hier mal die Befehlskette klar gemacht haben.
Okay, ich lasse dir das mal... Dieses Album heißt bezeichnenderweise Windows.
Trotzdem ganz toll.
Gut, zurück zu dieser Schreibkultur. Wir hatten das ja hier vorher auch schon mal besprochen. Es gibt Weblogs eigentlich länger, als es den Begriff gibt.
Sag doch mal eine Jahreszeit, Tim.
Ach Gott, ich könnte mal so...
Es gibt so eine Mär, das ist also das erste, was man als Weblog bezeichnen könnte, im Prinzip schon die Log-Dateien vom Erfinder des Webs waren. Und dann auf der anderen Seite, es gab so eine Linksammlung von Marc Andresen, ich glaube auch 96, dem Macher von Netscape, die auch so 1996 in Netz auftauchte. Die wird auch oft als der Urvater des Webblogs bezeichnet.
Im Prinzip auch so die frühe Fähigkeit von dem Netscape Navigator, die Bookmarks als HTML-Datei zu speichern. Das war ja nicht ein anderes Format, sondern die haben einfach gleich HTML genommen. Das war zwar nicht besonders lesbar, aber hatte den großen Vorteil, dass wenn man seine Bookmarks selber in einem per Web-Server zugänglichen Verzeichnis speicherte, andere Leute eben auch die eigenen Bookmarks oder eben man auch selbst auf seine eigenen Bookmarks zugreifen konnte über das Web. Das mag auch ein Auslöser gewesen sein. Insbesondere dieser Methode mit sehr wenigen Mitteln, diese eigene Information weiterzumachen.
War das am Anfang eher so eine technische Geschichte? Also dass es eher so wirklich das, was man so abgesurft hatte, was man als links empfehlenswert fand, dass die dann manifestiert wurden, gelockt wurden in einem Weblog?
Ja, das war es im Prinzip schon. Also die ersten, die ich so kenne, waren tatsächlich in dieser Art, dass es also tatsächlich ein Logbuch der Datenreisen durchs Internet war. Und dann, wie ich mal in einem Definitionsversuch auch gelesen habe, also ein Logbuch mit bissigen bis sarkastischen Kommentaren dazu. Das ist ein Stil, den ich immer noch versuche, bis heute zu pflegen. Auch so ein bisschen. Das war es im Prinzip dann erst einmal. Ich glaube, den richtigen Durchbruch, also die ersten Sachen waren ja alle noch mehr oder weniger auch mit handgestrickter Software gemacht. Den richtigen Durchbruch gab es dann eigentlich erst Ende der 90er, also 1999, als dann mit Blogger, Con und ähnlichen Software auf dem Markt kamen, die es eben erlaubte, das ins Netz zu stellen, ohne dass man Ahnung von HTML haben musste oder sonst irgendetwas. Sondern man machte einfach ein Browserfensterchen auf. Man kann davon halten, was man will, ob ein Browserfensterchen die ideale Editierumgebung ist. Aber man machte ein Browserfensterchen aus, schrieb etwas rein, machte einen Klick und es stand im Netz. Ich glaube, das ist auch wichtig, diese Unmittelbarkeit des Publizierens, dass man also sofort das, was man geschrieben hat, eben dann erst nicht mehr noch tagelang mit sich rumträgt oder so. Man hat es geschrieben, man macht einen Klick und es steht im Netz und alle können es lesen.
Was so ein bisschen auch das Faszinosum des Ganzen ausmacht, weil ich immer noch feststellen kann, dass so die Seiten, bei denen ich mal vorbeiserfe, oft die Informationen viel, viel eher haben, als sie so bei den klassischen Medien ankommen. Das heißt, wenn man irgendwann so seine kleine Community zusammen hat und man findet da Informationen, findet man die, wenn man Glück hat, sogar bis zu einer Woche früher, als so die klassischen Medien aufgreifen, weil es vielleicht nicht unbedingt journalistischen Standards standhält. Also dass man es nicht mit 18 Quellen abgesichert hat oder ähnliches, sondern dass man einfach sagt, ich habe da was gesehen, das könnte demnächst interessant werden.
Ja, das ist auf der einen Seite richtig, auf der anderen Seite, ich habe es bei mir gemerkt, je populärer man wird, desto mehr muss man sich auch wieder an journalistische Standards halten, sonst kriegt man Ärger mit den Anwältinnen. Also das kann man sehr gut machen, wenn man 30 oder 100 oder 150 Leser hat, aber wenn man mehr Leser hat, hat man auch wieder viele Leser, die auch Anwälte im Rücken haben, dann wird es wieder schwieriger.
Gut, das bewahren wir uns fürs Ende auf, wenn wir zu Bett gehen und alle Angstträume haben möchten.
Wir waren jetzt stehen geblieben. Was waren denn eigentlich die ersten bekannten Weblogs? Abgesehen davon, wollte ich vorhin schon erwähnen, die Macintosh-Szene war eigentlich sehr umtriebig beim Erarbeiten, beim Sich-Erarbeiten des Webs. Also die ersten wirklich lesbaren und auch halbwegs betrachtbaren Webseiten kamen eigentlich so aus der Szene heraus. Und da war eben auch schon sehr viel in einem sehr persönlichen Stil. macintosh.com würde ich dann nennen und später natürlich vor allem und auch heute eigentlich immer noch das populärste Webblog, auch wenn es sich selber eigentlich nie als solches bezeichnet hat, interessanterweise, ist Slashdot. Was ja auch so diese Daily-Update-Manier hat, auch eine sehr hohe Beteiligungsfrequenz hat, extrem auch von den Kommentaren lebt, ein gutes Kommentarsystem hat, was von vielen Leuten mitgepflegt wird, weil man muss nicht alles lesen, sondern man kann sich sozusagen nur die Kommentare anzeigen lassen, von denen anderen schon gesagt haben, da steht auch was halbwegs Brauchbares drin. Also das einen sehr hohen Nutzwert auch hat.
Wobei Slashdots gibt es schon länger, als es den Begriff Weblog gibt. Ich glaube seit 1997 ist Slashdot auf dem Markt und der Begriff Weblogs ist so weit, wie ich weiß, also tatsächlich erst 1998, 1999 aufgetaucht.
Doch schon so früh, ja?
Ja 1999 auf jeden Fall. Also die ersten Weblogs, die sich tatsächlich als Weblogs bezeichnen, die ich kenne, die sind schon 1999 auch da gewesen. Also das heißt früh, ich bin auch seit 2000, seit Mai 2000 mit meinem Schockquellenreiter als Weblog bezeichnet dabei.
Gibt es irgendjemanden, der diesen Begriff erfunden hat? Der den auf seine Seite geschrieben hat? Der damit angefangen hat, von dem man es weiß?
Also wenn man das jetzt so rumsteht, gibt es bestimmt der Weiner, der behauptet, er hat das erfunden. Aber ich weiß es nicht.
Das ist doch mal ein eigener Tagespunkt heute. Abteilung verrückte Texaner.
Also gut, dann sagen wir grundsätzlich verrückte Amerikaner. Die Amerikaner haben es sowieso relativ weit nach vorne getrieben. Man muss sagen, dass diese Weblog-Prinzipien in Amerika schon viel größeren Anklang gefunden haben, wo man sich fragt, ob das überhaupt noch das ist, was wir uns darunter vorstellen, weil es teilweise sehr tagebuchähnliche Sachen sind, die da hingeschrieben werden. In Deutschland ist es noch nicht so publik, aber da wollen wir heute Abend für sorgen. Jedenfalls ist jetzt die Hanna am Telefon aus Berlin, die selber einen Weblog macht. Hallo Hanna.
Hallo.
Was machst du für einen Weblog?
Also ich bin bei Live Journal angemeldet. Das ist so, also nicht eine Seite, die ich selber erstellt hab mit HTML, sondern da meldet man sich halt an unter livejournal.com und dann kriegt man halt sozusagen ein kleines Tagebuch und ganz viele andere Leute haben auch bei livejournal.com so einen Blog und dann kann man halt bloggen da, was auch immer und der Vorteil ist, dass man kontrollieren kann, wer mitliest sozusagen.
Und was schreibst du so rein?
Also ich schreib da schon so wie ein Tagebuch. Also ich schreib jetzt so nicht meine Ängsten, Geheimnisse oder so, aber irgendwie keine Ahnung, was ich heute gemacht hab und halt bla bla. Oder wenn mich mal was bedrückt, weil ich weiß halt, wer mitliest und nicht, dass dann halt irgendjemand mitliest. Und naja, also es ist schon so vertraulich manchmal.
Woher weißt du, wer mitliest? Ich meine, das steht auch im Web.
Ja, ja, aber bei Livejournal gibt es ja so, naja, schwer zu erklären, also die Einträge, die kann man Fans-only schreiben. Und das heißt, man hat eine Fanslist von allen anderen, die Livejournal schreiben. Und dann, wenn man seine Einträge Fans-only stellt, dann dürfen halt nur die mitlesen, die auf der Friendsliste sind. Und damit hat man das dann kontrolliert.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt wollten, könnten wir gar nicht lesen?
Nee, genau.
Wie viele Leute sind das sozusagen, die da mitlesen bei dir?
Na ja, also knapp 20, sag ich mal.
Tun die das auch?
Ja.
Und schreiben die dann auch so einen Weblog?
Ja, genau, machen die. Aber die haben dann auch andere Friends noch und so, also nicht nur mich sozusagen, und halt alle anderen, die auf meine Fans stehen. Also es sind ganz schön viele Leute, die im Live-Journal tätig sind.
Ja, das ist natürlich interessant, dass das schon so eine eigene... Ich meine, was hast du denn für so ein Gefühl? Ersetzt oder erweitert das eure Kommunikation?
Ich würde sagen, es erweitert unsere Kommunikation ganz schön stark, weil das ist eigentlich für mich nicht nur so ein Tagebuch, sondern auch so, wenn ich jetzt mal eine Frage an irgendjemanden habe. Ich kenne auch ziemlich viele dadurch, die auch in Berlin wohnen, zum Beispiel Antonia. Und naja, die habe ich über Live-Journal kennengelernt. Und naja, wenn ich sie mal irgendwas fragen will, zum Beispiel, wollen wir uns heute mal treffen oder so, dann schreibe ich das ins Live-Journal und da kriegt sie es am schnellsten mit. Also es ist besser, als wenn ich sie jetzt anrufe.
Gibt es auch Kommentarmöglichkeit bei euch?
Jaja, auf jeden Fall. Dann kann man auch gucken, wer kommentieren soll und so. Weil wenn es Franzoni geschrieben ist, dann können halt auch nur deine Fans kommentieren, weil die es auch nur lesen können.
Schön. Und das ist für dich aber wahrscheinlich dann so eine sehr, sehr private Sache, wo du jetzt gar nicht Sachen schreiben möchtest, die dann irgendwann mal, dass du sagst, jetzt kann ich das so gut, jetzt möchte ich auch, dass ganz, ganz viele das lesen und ich würde es mal öffentlich machen oder hast du schon mal mit dem Gedanken gespielt?
Nee, nee, also ich mach mein, also ich hab es erstmal grundsätzlich Franzoni gemacht, aber wenn mal irgendwas ist, keine Ahnung, was ich mal so in den Raum stellen würde, dann mach ich es halt auch mal einen Eintrag, nicht Franzoni. Also kann man von Eintrag zu Eintrag variieren, sozusagen.
Und liest du auch öffentliche Webblogs jetzt außerhalb dieses Live-Journalsystems?
Ja, mach ich eigentlich auch. Also wenn ich mal an irgendeinem vorbeikomme, dann lese ich mir das auch schon mal durch und so. Also es ist jetzt nicht so, nee, nur Live-Journal und nichts anderes.
Und wie viel Zeit verbringst du so gewöhnlich pro Tag damit?
Ich bin eigentlich relativ lange am Computer. Also wenn ich jetzt nicht gerade etwas anderes zu tun hab, so schon relativ manchmal vier Stunden am Tag. Und dann ist halt die größte Zeit auch Live-Journal. Naja, also relativ lange.
Vier Stunden ist ja schon ein guter Grad an...
Das ist mehr als ich für meinen Webblog aufbringe.
Naja, aber über den Tag verteile ich das. Ich geh dann, weiß ich nicht, wenn ich irgendwie von der Schule komme oder so, geh ich mal gucken, oh toll, hat irgendjemand was geschrieben. Und dann mach ich Computer wieder aus. Und dann zwei Stunden später geh ich halt noch mal gucken, oh toll, hat jemand was geschrieben. Und dann verteilt sich das so.
Und wie prüfst du das? Du lädst die anderen Webblogs dann einfach in den Webbrowser und schaust nach? Oder hast du da noch so eine andere Funktionalität, die dir automatisch Bescheid sagt, wenn sich was geändert hat bei den anderen?
Also es ist so, wenn man einen Live-Journal-Webblog hat, dann hat man halt sozusagen auch seine Seite, wo alles schön drauf steht. Und dann gibt es einen tollen Link. Oben, der gleich da oben steht, dann kann man da drauf klicken. Friends heißt der und dann sind alle deine Leute, die du in der Fansliste hast, die letzten Einträge von denen kann man dann sehen. So, also relativ praktisch.
Sehr, sehr stark auf Community. Schon ausgelegter, wenn wir heute Abend dann auch nochmal ein paar Beispiele geben. Was ist da so für verschiedene Möglichkeiten gibt, so einen Webblog anzuleben? Und was ist so für Sachen gibt, die eher für einen so zum Publizieren nur gedacht sind? Oder eben das wie Live-Journal hatten wir gar nicht auf der Liste gehabt.
Das ist für mich neu.
Ich musste auch schon was sagen.
Nee, ich kannte es. Wir hatten es vergessen. Ja, wir hatten es richtig vergessen.
Wie bist du denn da drauf gekommen eigentlich? Hast du die anderen mitgerissen oder bist du mitgerissen worden?
Ich bin mitgerissen worden, denke ich mal. Ich habe mit meiner Homepage angefangen, denke ich mal. Keine Ahnung, wie es kam. Und dann bin ich da auch in meinem Internet rumgeschwürt. Und dann kam ich halt irgendwann auf die Live-Journals. Und dann dachte ich mir, Mensch, du brauchst da auch. Und man braucht aber so eine Code dafür, um sich ein Live-Journal zu beschaffen, und entweder man kauft sich die. Und das ist relativ teuer. Also das kostet schon was und das kostet auch Dollar, weil es ist ja in Amerika halt. Oder man lässt sich halt von Freunden so ein Code schenken, weil immer wenn man ein Live-Journal bekommt, bekommt man auch noch einen extra Code dazu, den man dann irgendwie weitergeben kann. Und so kommt man dann an kostenlose Journals, aber da diese Codes nicht so in der Gegend rumliegen, sag ich mal, braucht man schon eine Weile, bis man irgendwie an ein Journal kommt. Aber da gibt es dann schon wieder extra Communities, um so einen Code zu kriegen. Also schon ein ganz schön verstrecktes Netz.
Und einer war der Erste, der es sich damals gekauft hat.
Genau.
Der Einzige, der das Ding füttert mit Dollars.
Genau, so ungefähr ist das, denke ich mal. Also ich denke mal, es gibt ungefähr 90 Prozent, sind kostenlose Accounts und die anderen.
Na schön, dann überleben die ja auch von livejournal.com. Hanna, vielen Dank für den Anruf.
Ja und eins würde ich noch kurz sagen, du hast ja vorhin gesagt, es gibt LiveJournal-Führer und LiveJournal-Führerinnen. Und ich würde mal sagen, dass mehr Frauen, also Blog meine ich jetzt, dass mehr Frauen hier Webblog machen, betreiben.
Oh, das ist doch immer eine gute Theorie.
Mehr Frauen als Männer oder mehr Frauen als Frauen andere Sachen machen? Ja, ist das dein Eindruck?
Ja, also würde ich schon sagen.
Hast du vielleicht einfach mehr Freundinnen als Freunde?
Naja, also was ich jetzt mitgekriegt habe, waren eigentlich mehr weibliche Betreiber. Aber ich kann mich ja auch irgendeinem.
Genau, das ist doch mal schön, dass es hingestellt ist. Also wenn ihr meint, es wäre genau andersrum, 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer für euch heute Abend. Hanna, vielen Dank erstmal. Gruß nach Berlin und fleißig schreiben über dieses Erlebnis.
Ja genau, und noch schönen Gruß an alle Live-Journaler.
Die werden jetzt bestimmt auch zuhören.
Ihr könnt anrufen, das ist ernst gemeint. Wenn ihr selber Webblog-Schreiber seid, Verfasser oder Verfasserinnen, ihr dürft auch Männer sein, also ihr müsst euch jetzt nicht abschrecken lassen, dann 0331 77 97 110. Wir möchten natürlich Geschichten hören und wir möchten nicht selber erzählen, was wir den ganzen Tag machen, sondern wir möchten von euch die Empfehlung haben. Lohnt sich das überhaupt so ein Teil zu schreiben? Lohnt es sich vor allen Dingen vielleicht für 20 Leute so ein Teil zu schreiben? Oder schreibt ihr für viel, viel mehr? Ich nehme mal an, die Hanna, Jörg, ist genau das Gegenteil zu dir. Die schreibt für so einen ganz kleinen Kreis. Du schreibst pro Tag für wie viele Leute, die deine Seite lesen?
Ich hab zwischen 3.000 und 4.000 Pageviews pro Tag und 2.500 Visits ungefähr. Ich hab im letzten Monat 55.000 Visits und ungefähr 100.000 Pageviews gehabt.
Und das sind nicht alles Leute, die auf deiner Friendsliste stehen?
Ich habe keine Friendsliste. Bei mir war alles... Wenn man lange genug durch einen Webblog wie den Schockwellenreiter führt, hat man irgendwann auch wirklich keine Freunde mehr. Bei mir war es von Anfang an öffentlich. Es war eben auch nie als Tagebuch geplant, sondern eher als eine Art Notizbuch für mich, in dem ich tatsächlich auch Links gesammelt habe. Einmal natürlich, weil ich mich selber erinnern wollte. Zum anderen auch, weil ich natürlich auch den Eindruck hatte, ich habe hier etwas zu sagen und ich habe der Welt etwas mitzuteilen. Also ohne dieses Mitteilungsbedürfnis macht man das, glaube ich, auch nicht.
Stimmt, das geht mir auch ähnlich. Also dieses Selbstnotieren steht auch echt oben. Sehr oft gemacht, dass ich mir einfach Bookmarks, selbst wenn ich mir tatsächlich einen Bookmark gemacht habe, ich habe den einfach nicht mehr gefunden, weil mir einfach der Speicherkontext irgendwie gefehlt hat. Aber in dem Moment, wo man selber darüber schreibt, und es gibt ja sehr unterschiedliche Art und Weisen, wie man seinen Webblock schreibt. Also Jörg macht das ja sehr knapp, hat dafür relativ viel. Ich und du ja auch. Wir schreiben ja deutlich weniger. So mal ein paar Tage nix, dann mal vielleicht auch zwei, drei Sachen pro Tag, je nachdem, wenn man so drauf ist. Aber man muss halt immer diese gewisse Schwelle überschreiten, ist es mir jetzt was wert? Aber in dem Moment, wo man es tut, fügt man ja dann auch immer irgendwas Persönliches mit rein. Also über die Bewertung hinaus und versucht es dann auch, sagen wir mal, für den potentiellen Leser ein bisschen zu umranken und in Kontext zu setzen.
Ja, und vor allen Dingen auch, wenn man das einmal auch aufgeschrieben hat und sich dann auseinandergesetzt hat, ist es auch etwas tiefer im Gedächtnis vergraben. Man behält es dann damit auch. Und das andere ist eben halt, ich hab ja mit Manila angefangen als Webblock-Software und die hatten schon eine, wenn auch nicht ganz so gut, aber sie hatten eine eingebaute Suchfunktion. Das heißt also, wenn man, und die hatten solche Kategorien, wo man es ablegen konnte, man konnte, also was weiß ich sagen, okay, das ist jetzt die Kategorie HTML. Da sammle ich meine ganzen HTML-Tricks und dann, wenn ich dann irgendwas suche, konnte man eben halt einfach nur durch diese Kategorie dann durchgehen dann dabei. Oder eben halt tatsächlich die eingebaute Suchfunktion. Das hat mir am Anfang sehr geholfen. Ich hab dann, wie ich dann später gewechselt habe mit der Software, habe ich gerade dies besonders vermisst. Also diese Suchfunktion ist schon sehr nützlich. Später hat es sich dann ergeben mit der Suchfunktion, dass, wenn ein populäres Webblock wird recht häufig von Google durchsucht, man findet mich schneller bei Google, als wenn ich meine eigene Suchfunktion nutze.
Das ist ganz nett, da können wir heute Abend auch noch mal drüber sprechen, die Möglichkeit zu sehen, wo die Leute denn hergekommen sind, wenn sie die eigene Seite besucht haben. Und da benützen wir beide, glaube ich, auch das gleiche Tool, nämlich SiteMeter, was ein kostenloser Service ist, sitemeter.com, den man auf seiner Seite einrichten kann. Und da kann man dann sehen, okay, der oder diejenigen kam von der und der Seite. Und das Lustige ist, dass wenn jemand von Google kommt, immer schön genau in der Zeile zu lesen ist, nach welchen Begriffen der gesucht hat.
Ja, ich benutze allerdings diese Referor-Funktion von SiteMeter nicht, weil die schreibt kein sauberes HTML. Und da ich meinen Weblog immer ein sauberes HTML haben will, habe ich die ausgeschaltet. Ich gucke schon in den Server-Statistiken selber nach, da ich das ja auf meinem eigenen Server habe.
Ja, ich bin ja eine Pozzau. Ich schreibe dreckiges HTML. Aber ist auf jeden Fall schön zu sehen, was da so steht. Und nach welchen Begriffen die gesucht haben. Weil es manchmal Begriffe sind, wo man sich selber fragt, ich habe diese Begriffe doch noch nie benutzt, in dem was ich geschrieben habe. Da steht dann irgendwie so Hundescheiße und Challenger. Du denkst, wie kommt jemand auf die Idee, Hundescheiße in Zusammenhang mit Challenger zu suchen? Und warum findet der das bei mir? Aber das sind alles Fragen, die wir gleich noch klären werden, weil wir haben jetzt erst mal Nachrichten. Ihr könnt weiter anrufen. Nur 331 77 97 110. Wir möchten gleich mit euch quatschen. Jörg, du musst mal Platz machen für den Basti, damit wir hier so ein bisschen Nachrichten unter das Volk bringen können. Börner, bist du bereit?
Wenn Fritz rundum hält sich, dann 91, 9.
22.30 Uhr. Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht bewölkt es sich immer mehr. Es regnet ab und zu. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 4 Grad. Morgen ist es vormittags noch regner. Später dein Freundlicher bei maximal 9 bis 11 Grad. Und jetzt die Meldungen mit Bastian Börner.
Der Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und Bundesrat hat seine Beratung auf den 10. Dezember vertagt. Eine Stunde hatten Vertreter von Regierung und Opposition nach Kompromissen bei den geplanten Reformen gesucht. Beide Seiten sprachen danach von tiefgreifenden Meinungsverschiedenheiten in der Steuer- und Arbeitsmarktpolitik. Aus Protest gegen Kürzungen im Bildungsetat haben Studenten die PDS-Zentrale im Karl-Lieb-Knecht-Haus in Berlin besetzt. Die PDS teilte mit, sie betrachte die Studenten als ihre Gäste. Für morgen Mittag planen Studenten aller drei Berliner Universitäten eine Demonstration vom Potsdamer Platz zum Roten Harathaus in Mitte. In einem der größten deutschen Rückübertragungsprozesse hat eine jüdische Erbengemeinschaft Recht bekommen. Das Bundesverwaltungsgericht sprach den Erben ein Grundstück in der Brandenburgischen Gemeinde Teltow Seehof zu. Die Entscheidung ist Grundlage für über 700 weitere Verfahren. Die Deutsche Polizeigewerkschaft fordert angesichts steigender Gewalt an Schulen Taschenkontrollen am Schuleingang. Auch eine Videoüberwachung auf den Schulhöfen sei sinnvoll, sagte Landeschef der Polizeigewerkschaft Tasler, dem Berliner Kurier. Die Zahl der Gewalttaten an Schulen hat laut Kurieren in den letzten beiden Jahren um 66 Prozent zugenommen. Und zum Sport im Fußball Champions League Spiel Stuttgart gegen Glasgow Rangers steht es zurzeit 1 zu 0 für Stuttgart. Albe Berlin hat in der Basketball Euro League den ersten Sieg geschafft. Nach drei Niederlagen hintereinander gelang dem deutschen Meister ein. 95 zu 89 gegen Tau Vitoria aus Spanien. Damit haben sie ihre Chance auf das Erreichen der Zwischenrunde gewahrt. Und der Verkehr auf Rützde hat keine Meldung, deswegen gute Fahrt.
So, bei uns könnt ihr natürlich grundsätzlich mitmachen, ohne Leibesvisitation, ne, nur dass ihr dabei bleibt. Tom.
Ja, hi, hier ist die Perle und... Ich wünsch mir......Sina Aguilera. Deutschland sucht den Superstar.
Ein schönes Lied von Mennewolf.
Meine Familie. Einfach nur anrufen, wünschen und grüßen.
031 70 97 130 Open Box. Musikwunsch-Erfüllungsradio-Sendung mit Grüßen. Immer Montag bis Freitag. Ab 19 Uhr. Uns im Radio.
Wir sind wieder da, nicht? Und hier Tim Pridlow ist schon mal einen kleinen Rolls-Ball losgelassen, damit doch sofort jeder weiß, dass wir da sind. Er hat das Chaosradio auf Fritz. Wir haben noch gute zweieinhalb Stunden Zeit. Thema heute Abend Webblogs bzw. man möchte ja ein... Man möchte ja einen Round- und Überbegriff haben. Und wir haben es vorhin schon mal so kurz angerissen. Es ist immer sehr, sehr schwer, auch für die Community selber gewesen, zu definieren, was Webblogs eigentlich sind für diejenigen, die jetzt einschalten. Es ist so eine Mischung aus...
Sag bloß nicht Tagebuch.
Nein, ich sag nicht Tagebuch. Also sagen wir es so, es ist eine Mischung von einer puren Link-Liste. Also von einem Logbuch von links bis zum Logbuch von Gedanken auch. Oder eben halt kritischem Umgang mit dem Themen. Deswegen ist es sehr, sehr spannend, Webblogs manchmal zu lesen, auch wenn sie gut geschrieben sind vor allem, weil sie manchmal ganz, ganz kurz auf den Punkt bringen, dass sie sich zu dem und dem Thema äußern und das viel, viel besser ist als der Kommentar auf der Seite 3 der Tageszeitung, die man an dem Tag hätte lesen können. Das entdeckt man natürlich nur, wenn man sich drauf einlässt. Es ist auch viel dabei, was man vielleicht gar nicht durchfindet. Vielleicht zum einen, weil es schund ist, zum anderen, weil es nicht unbedingt der Stil ist, den man mag, aber dass der Stil sehr, sehr weit rauskommt und dass die Person an sich, die dieses Webblog schreibt, sehr weit rauskommt, das ist Sinn der Sache. Das kann man auf jeden Fall schon mal festlegen. Darum geht es heute Abend. Wenn ihr auch ein Webblog schreibt oder wenn ihr sagt, Entschuldigung mal, könntest du es noch mal erklären, 0331 77 97 110, die Nummer vom Chaos Radio heute Abend mit dem Studio vom Chaos Computer Club der Tim, der Jörg Kanten vom Schockwellen Reiter zu finden unter schockwellenreiter.de. Wir wollen dir mal noch ein paar tausend Hits bescheren heute Abend.
Dann hoffe ich ja auch.
Deswegen bin ich ja da. Da könnt ihr einfach mal drauf gucken, was der so macht. Und meine Person Max von Spitz. Jetzt übernimmst du, Tim, ich kann nicht mehr.
Die Deutschblogger bauen ab. Ja, wir hatten gerade schon in der Pause eine schöne Diskussion ausgelöst jetzt hier auch durch die letzte Anruferin, so die nochmal extra darauf hingewiesen hat, dass viele Mädchen auch am Start sind. Das ist von Anfang an zu beobachten gewesen. Und generell gibt es interessante Dichten. Also wir hatten hier auch gerade nochmal den Fakt. Also es gibt ja, wie das immer so ist, im Internet, wenn sich da irgendetwas technisch entwickelt, dann ist es halt meist doch irgendwie die USA, die auch in Sachen Software da voranschreitet. Und manchmal gibt es eben auch noch andere Länder, die mithalten.
Es gab ja im Mai diese Blogtal-Konferenz, ich hab die glaube ich vorhin schon mal erwähnt, und da waren auch Gäste aus Polen dabei. Und es gibt in Polen eine unglaubliche Webblog-Dichte, die bei weitem viel, viel höher ist, als die hier in Deutschland ist. Und auch da sind die meisten Teilnehmer, sind Mädchen oder junge Frauen in diesem Webblog-Bereich. Zumindest sagte das die Polin, die uns diesen Lista auf dieser Konferenz vorstellte. Und sie erklärte das ganz witzig. Sie erklärte das damit, dass gerade auf dem Land in Polen sonst sowieso nichts los ist. Man kann eben nur Webblog führen und sonst gar nichts. Also man sollte, was auch viel vergessen wird, weil wir natürlich oft davon ausgehen, dass also wenn was im Internet ist, ist es also in Englisch. Es gibt also auch sprachliche Communities. Eine sehr große, die ich ein wenig kenne, ist halt die Brasilianisch, also die Portugiesisch sprechende, der Portugiesisch sprechende Bereich. Oder auch dort gibt es eine ziemlich hohe Dichte. Und was ich weniger kenne, weil meine Sprachkenntnisse da nicht ausreichen, also was ich nur aus der Literatur und aus den anderen Webblogs kenne, ist eben halt der Bereich der persischen Webblogs, wo sie auch tatsächlich eine Funktion haben, die ich mir ein bisschen für meinen Webblog auch immer gewünscht habe. Nämlich durch eine Funktion tatsächlich so etwas wie gegen Öffentlichkeit zu sein. Wir wissen alle, dass es in Persien mit der Demokratie nicht gerade so gut bestellt ist. Und persische Webblogs sind oft ein Ausdruck oder sind tatsächlich ein Ausdruck gegen Zensur. Also die Möglichkeit überhaupt zu publizieren. Deswegen sitzen die meisten Hoster, die persische Webblogs hosten, auch in Frankreich und eben nicht in Persien selber.
Ich würde auch die USA damit erwähnen. Also jetzt gerade während des Irakkriegs und insbesondere im Vorfeld des Irakkriegs, als ja einfach mal die globale Mausperre über alles Amerikanische geworfen wurde.
Stimmt.
So waren einfach die Webblogs in den USA. Zumindest die, die ich gelesen habe, einfach sehr auch eine Gegenöffentlichkeit.
Es gibt eine sehr große Öffentlichkeit von oppositionellen politischen Webblogs in den USA. Also eins, was ich besonders liebe, ist Booknotes. Das ist Booknotes ManilaSidesCom von einem Texaner, der auch zeigt, dass nicht alle Texaner George Bush-Anhänger sind. Eigentlich war es mal, was der Name seines Webblogs schon sagt, sollte das mal Literatur vorstellen und es ist also ein Zeichen dieses schleichenden Machtübernahme von George Bush und den Republikanern. Es ist sehr stark politisch geworden und ich finde es ist ein phantastisches und leseswertes Webblog auch.
Ja und das ist was bringt, also dass tatsächlich sie auch die klassischen Medien davon beeindrucken lassen, was da passiert und nicht sagen, ja gut, das ist halt irgendeine private Seite, da schreibt jemand seine Meinung auf So What. Ich fand das ganz spannend, das war damals auch während des Irakkrieges in Amerika. Da hat ein Kameramann von CNN, glaube ich, Kevin Seitz, habt ihr das gelesen zufällig? Er hat Kevin Seitz einen Webblog gemacht, der war Kameramann bei CNN und hat seine persönliche Meinung, unabhängig von dem, wie die Beiträge vom Tenor her waren, die er gedreht hat, eben auch zu seiner Zeit als Erinnerung des Irakkrieges da reingeschrieben. Die haben ihm das dann verboten, haben gesagt, also entweder du machst das oder du arbeitest bei uns. Und das fanden die schon wichtig genug, um dem armen Mann da Druck zu machen, der da eigentlich nur seine persönlichen Eindrücke geschildert hat, die so ein bisschen über seine Arbeit hinausgegangen sind.
Ja, wobei, ich weiß nicht, ob es nur allein die Sprachgrenze ist. Es gibt wenig Deutsch, also gemessen an dem, wie viele englisch sprechende oder englisch lesende Menschen gibt, gibt es wenig deutsch lesende Menschen, ist auch die Leseranzahl der amerikanischen Webblogs bedeutend höher. Amerika ist ein größeres Land natürlich auch, aber ich glaube auch, dass es schon ein wenig damit zu tun hat, dass die Information über die Massenmedien auch so wahnsinnig abgeflacht ist. In den USA, dass man da also tatsächlich Hunger hat nach anderer Information, auch nicht deswegen, also auch die Popularität. Also gerade oppositioneller Webblogs oder eben auch Webblogs, die etwas außerhalb des Mainstreams stehen und so sehr groß ist.
Aber auch der Mainstream greift nach den Webblogs. Gutes Beispiel ist dieser aufkommende Wahlkampf in den USA, wo jetzt die Kandidaten...
Jeder andere kranche Präsidentschaftskandidat führt ein Webblog.
Ist es mittlerweile so, dass sie alle eins haben? Ich weiß nicht, dieser Dean hat noch nicht damit angefangen.
Ja, ich weiß es nicht so genau, aber sie fangen alle. Aber die lassen die natürlich schreiben. Die schreiben sie nicht selber. Vollkommen klar.
Aber es ist halt schon interessant, dass sie das zumindest auch... Also es ist halt wirklich eine aufgenommene Kultur. Es ist also nichts, was nebenbei stattfindet, sondern in zunehmendem Maße noch mal auch seine...
Der Howard Dean hat sich damit sein Ding finanziert, größtenteils, soweit ich das gelesen hab.
Hat sich womit was finanziert?
Er hat sich seinen Wahlkampf finanziert. Also weil er einfach eine große Community damit zusammengestellt hat, die ihm dann auch finanzielle Hilfe zukommen lassen. Das hätte er so nicht geschafft. Also es ist nicht klassischer Wahlkampf, wie er in den USA normalerweise betrieben wird.
Wo wir gerade bei diesen Beispielen sind, auch mit dieser persönlichen Öffentlichkeit, gab es auch vor ein paar Wochen den Fall eines zu dem Zeitpunkt noch bei Microsoft arbeitenden Menschens. Das ist dieses Eclectism Weblog. Ich hab jetzt den Namen des jungen Manns vergessen, der eines Tages einen Laster auf den Microsoft Campus gefahren und loot ein Stapel G5s aus. Das hat er dann einfach mal grinsenderweise fotografiert und das Foto dann aufs Weblog gestellt. Eine Woche später war er halt kein Mitarbeiter mehr bei microsoft.com, weil die das irgendwie gesehen haben und als Verstoß gegen die heiligen Regeln. Keine Ahnung, wie sie das im Einzelnen formuliert haben. Auf jeden Fall haben sie ihn dann gekickt. Er fand es zwar nicht so richtig toll, aber hat es dann auch eher mit Grinsen zur Kenntnis genommen und hatte danach auch mehr damit zu tun, den Slashdot-Effekt auf seinem Weblog zu verkraften und hat ihm auf jeden Fall viele Leser gebracht.
0331 77 97 110, die Nummer. Eine kleine Einleitung haben wir hier immer gemacht, damit ihr ungefähr wisst, worum es geht. Wenn ihr auch Weblogs schreibt oder gerne lest oder gerne lesen möchtet und euch informieren möchtet, 0331 77 97 110 ist die Hotline von Fritz. Und am Telefon ist der Thorsten aus Köln. Hallo Thorsten. Thorsten, my love.
Ach komm.
Thorsten hat extra aus Köln angerufen. Das hört sich so an, als wäre er im Hintergrund noch zugange, um ganz ehrlich zu sein.
Warte mal, mal Musik weg.
Hallo Köln.
Wir hören uns sogar noch im Echo.
Wir hören uns aber multi im Echo. Ich würde mal sagen, die hört uns über Stream.
Hallo?
Ja, Thorsten. Hey, das Delay hat nicht... Ja, wir hören dich.
Ja, wir hören dich massiv, aber ich glaube, da ist eine kleine Schleife. Wir sind in einer endlosen Schleife gefangen.
Wir sind in einer Schleife gefangen. Ja, genau, hallo. Thorsten, tu mir einfach den Gefallen, ich sag's dir jetzt mal über den Stream, der wird dich in ungefähr fünf Minuten dann erreichen. Ruf uns einfach noch mal an, sei so lieb. Gruß nach Köln, Thorsten. Wir haben dich gehört, du uns allerdings nicht. Ich schmeiß dich noch mal raus, nur, dass du jetzt nicht traurig bist. Du kannst noch mal anrufen.
Apropos Stream, da fällt mir ein, dass uns heute leider kurz vor der Sendung der Server abgeraucht ist, mit dem wir normalerweise die MP3-Streams machen, sodass da schon eine gewisse Teilöffentlichkeit ausgeschlossen ist, weil es irgendjemand einen MP3-Stream aufsetzen kann. Und das dann tut, so möge er doch bitte hier anrufen und uns die URL mitteilen, dann geben wir sie gerne noch mit raus.
Ja, bitte. 0373.97.9110. Das ist Telefon, nur für den Fall, dass er das nicht kennt. Und die Katja aus Brandenburg ist dran. Hallo Katja. Oh Gottes Willen, geht das jetzt die ganze Zeit so oder was?
Katja?
Katja, ach verflucht, aus Brandenburg. Ich bin untröstlich.
Was schreiben Sie gerade wieder einen Webblog eintragen?
Nein, ich finde das halt doof, weil wir haben jetzt hier einen Mordsriemen runter geredet und jetzt dachte ich jetzt kommen wir endlich mal zum Zug, aber nichts ist. Mal sehen, was die Beatrice sagt. Hallo Beatrice.
Endlich jemand da.
Ich warte schon und höre und höre.
Du machst selber wahrscheinlich auch einen Webblog, oder? Dann erzähl doch mal ein bisschen. Was ist das für ein Teil? Was schreibst du da so rein?
Also ich bin so ein Designblogger, der Schockwellenreiter wird es vielleicht schon gehört haben. Weiß ich nicht, ich lese ihn zumindest.
Das finde ich schon mal schön, aber wie heißt dein Webblog?
Gedankensprudler.
Gedankensprudler, das würde ich mir mal entspannen. Und worüber schreibst du so? Nur mal für alle anderen?
Also ich schreibe eigentlich querbeet, ob jetzt das Linksinn aus dem Webb, die ich finde, private. Ja, eigentlich gemischt querbeet.
Und wann hast du damit angefangen? Wir hatten ja vorhin schon mal gefragt. Und die Hannah zum Beispiel wusste nicht so genau zu berichten, wann das wie angefangen hat. Weißt du noch, wo deine Ursprünge sind?
Also angefangen habe ich jetzt vor fast einem Jahr. Und drüber kommen bin ich über den Schmierblock, die Kirstin, die hatte bei Blogger Webblog und hat gemeint, wir könnten sowas auch ins Web stellen. Und dann hat mein Freund da mal ein bisschen rumprogrammiert und so haben wir unsere eigene Software entwickelt und unsere eigene Community aufgebaut.
Direkt eine ganze Community, sind das mehrere, die auf diesem Server laufen?
Wir haben inzwischen jetzt so 35, 40 Leute, die über uns bloggen.
Was ist das für eine selbstgeschriebene Software und auf welchem Server läuft die?
Das ist von Blueline Webdesign. Und mein Freund hat die halt eben programmiert. Selbstprogrammiert, das ist so LightCMS, CMS Richtung.
Kannst du mal eine URL rüber schießen, dass ich mir das mal angucken kann?
Was möchtest du denn?
Ja, irgendeine davon.
Dann nimmste www.bluelinewebdesign.de Danke.
Als wusste ich, dass der Jörg da hellhörig wird. Der zieht sich alles rein, was damit zu tun hat.
Mit oder ohne Bindestrich dazwischen?
Egal.
Und du meinst, du bist ein Designblogger?
Das ist, dass wir eben fertige Vorlagen entwerfen und die auf die Technik aufsetzen oder auch anbieten unsere Do-it-yourself. Und da können die Leute dann selber ihr Design reinsetzen und selbst ihren Webblog gestalten, wie sie wollen. Und die Technik liefern halt wir.
Ach, das heißt, du bist eigentlich mehr ein Blogdesigner als ein Designblogger?
Man kann beides nehmen.
Ich hätte jetzt mehr erwartet, dass du mehr über das Design schreibst als andersrum.
Nee, nee, nee. Also ich blogge schon richtig. Nur ich hab halt die Design...
Also wir haben sonst... Ich zumindestens habe sonst auch wieder viel Ärger. Also über Designbloggen ist genauso legitim wie über alles andere Bloggen.
Nein, nein. Also ich bin schon ein richtiger Blogger. Ich hab auch mehrere Blogs.
Und was macht ihr da genau? Also bietet ihr jetzt für... Nehmen wir mal an, heute Abend hört das einer und denkt sich, das möchte ich aber gerne gemacht bekommen. Dann macht ihr dem sozusagen gerne ein handgeschnitztes Blog.
Zum Beispiel, ja.
Und was kostet sowas? Wollt ihr dafür Geld zählen oder ist das für einen Spaß?
Ne, also aus den Vorlagen zum Beispiel, die wir schon... Wir haben so ungefähr 100 Vorlagen, die wir im Shop liegen haben und die kosten dann... Also wir vermieten mehr oder weniger die Technik für 5, 99 pro Monat.
Inklusive Server oder?
Ja, ist alles dabei.
Das ist aber interessant jetzt, weil du bist ja dann jemand der anbietenden Zunft. Da kannst du uns ja mal erzählen, wie das so die letzten Jahre war. Also von der Durststrecke über den Hype, über eine erneute Durststrecke. Und jetzt geht es euch gut? Oder wie läuft das so im Schnitt?
Ich denke, dass wir eigentlich noch nicht so lange am Markt sind. Wir machen das jetzt in diesem Jahr. Und im Großen und Ganzen muss ich sagen, dass es nicht schlecht läuft. Es sind viele begeistert, die haben viel Spaß dran. Und ich habe ja auch Webseiten selber. Und man muss selber sagen, dass mir Webbloggen auch mehr Spaß macht, weil ich da mehr reinbringen kann. Das lebt einfach mehr.
Und wie viele Leute kommen da so und wollen so ein Ding haben?
Und wie viel habt ihr in der Community mittlerweile drin?
Also wir haben jetzt so, unser Freund schon gesagt, so um die 35 rum. Und wir wollen das eigentlich auch so in die kommerzielle Richtung mehr treiben. Wir haben eben auch schon Shop mit Blog und so Sachen, möchte man anbieten. Wir sind eigentlich schon ein bisschen dahinter, dass die Leute das eben auch kommerziell betreiben für sich. Bis hier Marketing damit machen.
Okay, also vielleicht, wenn ihr da jetzt gar nicht privat zuhört, sondern für ein Geschäft, könnt ihr euch das ja mal überlegen. Wobei wir heute Abend wahrscheinlich noch ein paar andere Alternativen, da könnten wir jetzt eigentlich mal durchstarten, oder Tim?
Wobei bei den Systemen, da können wir gleich drauf kommen. Aber ich habe schon eine Frage jetzt mal hier von der Werbung mal ganz abgesehen, die wir jetzt glaube ich breitbandig rübergebracht haben. Was ziehst du denn jetzt selber für dich heraus aus dem Webblogging?
Ja, erstens mal hole ich für mich raus das zweite Spektrum, was man im Web rumsourft und was man an Seiten findet, die Informationsquellen und überhaupt die Informationen, die für mich schon sehr positiv sind. Ich habe eine Menge davon.
Liest du primär sozusagen über die Webblogs und dann findest du alles andere oder ist das für dich eher die Zeit?
Ich lese viel über Webblogs, ja. Also so, dass ich von Webblog zu Webblog gehe und mir da alles Mögliche reinziehe und mir die Links durchsuche. Also für mich ist es ein hoher Informationswert.
Okidoki, vielen Dank für den Anruf erstmal.
Ja, ich danke auch.
Beatrice, Gruß nach Bayern.
Ja, danke.
Und da könnten wir eigentlich mal so einen kleinen Zwischenstand, nur weil jetzt gerade so ein Beispiel dafür klar ist. Und weil die Leute natürlich auch jetzt wissen wollen, wo kann ich sowas machen?
Ja, genau. Also man kann sich ja, die einfachste Methode denke ich, sind einfach diese fertigen Webblog-Services. Die schießen gerade so ein bisschen aus dem Boden. In den USA gibt es schon länger Blogger dort kommen, die das auch sehr stark...
Die jetzt von Google gekauft wurden?
Die von Google gekauft wurden. Was ganz interessant ist, über die Motivationen wurde da schon häufig gemutmaßt. Das können wir ja vielleicht auch nochmal machen.
Also ziemlich viel spekuliert auch dann dabei.
Ich denke, also eine, denke ich, gültige These ist, dass sie sich vor allem die Brands gekauft haben. Also die haben einfach die Leute gekauft, die als Personen für sie auch konkret einen Wert darstellen, um zukünftig zu entwickeln. Also ich meine, eine Webblock-Software, also die Komplexität der Software war ja zu dem Zeitpunkt, als sie es gekauft haben, jetzt auch nicht so monstermäßig. Also nichts, was man nicht hätte auch entwickeln können.
Also für diejenigen, die gar nicht wissen, was es ist, erzähl ich erstmal, was es ungefähr ist.
Das kommen wir schon wieder ab, bevor wir angefangen haben.
Und zwar gibt es grundsätzlich mehrere Möglichkeiten zu bloggen, was die ganzen Möglichkeiten gemeinsam ist. Ich habe es relativ einfach. Ich habe entweder eine Software auf meinem Computer oder wie bei Blogger der Fall, ich habe so ein Online-Interface, wo ich rangehen kann. Da kann ich dann einfach oben eintragen, das ist meine Überschrift. Das ist der Text, den ich gerne veröffentlichen möchte. Dann suche ich mir noch, wenn ich ganz faul bin, einfach eins von irgendwie 100 fertigen Designs aus. Das hatten wir gerade in dem Gespräch ja auch schon. Dann baut das Ding automatisch die Seite zusammen, wenn man will, auch auf dem eigenen Webspace für Lau von Blogger. Und dann hat man da mit Werbung eingeblendet, oder wenn man eben einen eigenen Webspace hat, ohne Werbung, dann kann man wunderbar seinen Teil direkt veröffentlichen, eine Webadresse angeben und dann steht das da. Da braucht man gar nichts von HTML zu wissen. Wenn man was weiß, kann man natürlich frickeln. Aber man braucht im Grunde nichts zu tun, außer seinen Gedanken niederzuschreiben und dann steht der da auch. Das ist im Grunde der Service, den die anbieten. Mit Bildern mittlerweile glaube ich auch.
Ja, also mittlerweile geht so ziemlich alles, was auch mit eher ausgefuchsteren Webblog-Softwaren geht. Ich meine dann sowieso, man kann unterscheiden drei Arten von Webblog-Softwaren. Einmal solche gehosteten Services, wo man tatsächlich bei zu einer Firma geht, wie Blogger oder wie UserLand mit Edity's Page oder eben halt auch zu Arndtville, also manchmal eine österreichische Community zu nennen, wo man dann eben halt sich einfach anmeldet. 26 als deutsches Unternehmen, wo man sich dann einfach anmeldet, dann kriegt man mehr oder weniger sofort ein Zugangskennwort und dann kann man loslegen. Dann gibt es eben halt schon etwas kompliziertere Möglichkeiten. Man braucht dazu eigenen Webspace. Man muss CGI's auf diesem Webspace irgendwie installieren können. Dann hat man im Prinzip genau die gleiche Funktionalität, die man auch bei diesen gehosteten Services hat, nur dass man es eben halt selber hat, dass es das eigene ist. Man hat schon viel mehr Möglichkeiten, an den Dingern zu drehen und so etwas zu machen. Und die dritte Möglichkeit ist eben halt, dass man alles auf dem eigenen Rechner macht, um dann mehr oder weniger automatisch das per FDP dann auf den Webspace runter lädt. Dann hat man allerdings auch nur die Form von statischen Seiten. Es ist dann schon wieder schwierig, Kommentare oder ähnliches zu haben. Da muss man dann doch schon wieder zusätzliche Dienste in Anspruch nehmen oder so. Aber das ist eben halt die Möglichkeit, die man nutzen kann, wenn man tatsächlich nur, was weiß ich, so eine Webvisitenkarte hat oder so, die nur statische Seiten erlaubt. Und damit kriegt man dann auch ähnlich schnell und ähnlich gut publiziert. Also die Möglichkeiten sind schon sehr vielfältig. Und ich glaube allen gemein ist, dass man mit keinen bis minimalen HTML-Kennnissen auskommt, um tatsächlich so eine Seite zu machen. Also man muss nicht stundenlang in HTML rumfrickeln und sich dann überlegen. Dann ist der Gedanke, wie man was publizieren wollte, eigentlich schon wieder weg. Auf der anderen Seite, es schadet natürlich nicht, wenn man HTML-Kennnisse hat. Aber das gilt für alle Kenntnisse irgendwie dann.
Können wir ja mal zwischenschießen. Wenn ihr irgendein Favorite habt, also wenn ihr irgendwas besonders schon lange benutzt oder gerne oder gerade umgestiegen seid oder sagt, wenn einer ein Anfänger ist, dann soll er doch das benutzen. Oder wenn er das und das machen will, dann ist das zu empfehlen. Jetzt anrufen, 031 70 97 1 1 0. Wir möchten natürlich von euch hören, welches System möglicherweise das Beste ist. Wir haben auch schon ein paar ausprobiert, aber das muss ja nicht unbedingt das Goldene los sein, was wir da gezogen haben.
Wollen wir ein paar erwähnen? Sollten wir auf jeden Fall noch.
Machen wir wohl.
An der Stelle. Sagen wir mal gerade zu dieser Zwischenwelt, dass das Einfachste ist. Ich hab ein Tool auf meinem Computer. Auf Macintosh gibt es dieses schöne iBlock, was da gerade hochkommt. Da muss man halt auch wenig Infrastruktur haben und wenig wissen und man kommt schon relativ weit. Das gleiche halt bei den komplett auf den Server basierten Systemen. Da ist es halt noch einen Zacken einfacher. Und dazwischen gibt es aber eben diese Sache mit eigener Server selbst installieren. Das ist natürlich ein etwas schwieriger Schwit, aber das ist sehr populär. Allen voran gibt es dort eine Software, die heißt Movable Type. Vom Namen her würde man erstmal gar nicht darauf kommen, dass es irgendwas mit Personal Publishing zu tun hat. Nennt sich aber auch Personal Publishing System, wie viele andere auch. Und ist sehr populär. Was man jetzt auch schon daran merkt, dass es so von den Spamern irgendwie ins Auge gepasst worden ist. Über den Kommentar da ihr Unwesen zu treiben. Aber Movable Type hat sich auch sehr bewährt. Hat schon so einiges bewegt in meinen Augen, was Einhaltung von Webstandards betrifft. Und ist auch sehr kreativ auf der technischen Seite. Zum Beispiel diese Trackback-Geschichte kommt ja von...
Da sollten wir aber nochmal erklären, was das dann ist auch.
Kommen wir später nochmal drauf. Was mir jetzt gerade noch einfiel ist, es gibt ja auch schon so Auswüchse, das ist beileibe nicht so populär, aber so dieses Mobile-Blogging, dass man halt so direkt per SMS auch Einträge in seinen Webblog vornehmen kann oder eben auch diese Audio-Blogging-Geschichte, die es halt noch mal weitertreibt, dass man eben das nicht per SMS macht, sondern eigentlich seinen Webblog anruft, kurz eine Aufnahme macht sozusagen über das Telefon. In dem Moment, wo man auflegt, ist es schon als eigener Eintrag auf der Webseite abrufbar. Da ist also sicherlich noch einiges im Busch.
Das ist ganz lustig zu gucken, zum Teil die Ursprünge. Ich erinnere mich Douglas Adams, mittlerweile lebt er ja leider nicht mehr, aber er hat am Ende ja nicht mehr so viel geschrieben, hatte dann auch im Internet-Boom mit einer Firma angefangen im Web und zwar wollte er den Hitchhikers Guide to the Galaxy tatsächlich verwirklichen und hat h2g2.com gemacht, was im Grunde genau das war. Also da sollten die Leute dann möglichst live im Café mit irgendwelchen mobilen Möglichkeiten eingeben, was sie an der Stelle in dem Café jetzt gerade scheiße fanden oder irgendwie toll im Museum oder sowas, was so ein bisschen den Charakter von Blogging auch hatte, weil man eben instantly und direkt ohne irgendwie Zwischengefühle oder abends erst am Rechner zu setzen das Ganze beurteilt hat, was da geschehen ist.
Wobei das also, ich denke doch eher den Charakter eines Wikis hatte, was ja auch noch mal so eine Publiziermöglichkeit im Web ist, die auch sehr schnell ist, weil die Idee war glaube ich auch bei diesem Hitchhiker's Guide to the Galaxy, dass die Sachen auch untereinander verlinkt sein sollten und also untereinander verlinkt. Weil ich glaube ein großer Unterschied zwischen einem Wiki als Publikation im Internet und einem Webblog als Publikation im Internet ist, dass ein Wiki eher nach innen geneigt ist, also innerhalb des Wikis verlinkt, dann Webblogs verlinken nach außen. Also ich hab in meinem Impressum stehen, alle Links sind externe Links. Und damit ist die Sache erledigt dann erst mal. Also Webblogs verlinken einfach nach außen dann.
Am Telefon ist der Thorsten aus Köln. Ich hoffe, er hört uns jetzt. Thorsten? Im Hintergrund sind wir wieder zu hören.
Hallo? Genau.
Thorsten, wieso hörst du uns eigentlich? Das kann doch nicht wahr sein. Machst du Voice-over-IP oder was machst du da für schräge Sachen? Ist das nicht ein normales Telefonnummer? Der hört uns einfach nicht.
Wir hören ihn, aber er hört uns nicht. Nur durch den Stream hörst du uns vielleicht. Das ist eine komplett neue Erfahrung für dich und für uns.
Das ist vielleicht auch ein Echo aus vergangenen Zeiten oder so.
Oder aus der Zukunft.
Also Thorsten, es tut mir super leid, aber entweder schreibst du deinen Webblog. Er hat jetzt nein gesagt. Auf welche Frage hat er jetzt geantwortet? Oh Gott, wir müssen das rückrechnen. Pass mal auf, wir machen das folgendermassen. Wir ignorieren jetzt mal das Delay und zoomen so gerne und sagen, Torsten, erzähl doch jetzt mal was über deinen Weblog.
Und das ist jetzt eine total ungewöhnliche Kommunikationssituation.
Fantastisch.
Hör mal, red mal einfach in einem durch. Ich weiß, das wirst du jetzt erst in 30 Sekunden entfangen, aber zähl einfach mal, mach den Ton von deinem Ding leise, sonst wirst du nämlich bescheuert. Und erzähl einfach mal ein bisschen, was du so machst, warum du angefangen hast. Das wollen wir direkt in den ganzen Strauß von Fragen stellen, oder?
Aber er hat nur einen einzigen Blog, also du musst das jetzt alles reintun. Ein Webblog-Eintrag bitte von dir, live, per Audio, und danach sind wir wieder dran.
Genau.
Okay, ich werd's mal versuchen. Ich bin jetzt ein ganz neuer Blogger, das heißt, vor zwei Monaten grad hat mich Hörkantel verlinkt und das hat mir sehr viele Besucher geschafft. Ich hab versucht, einen Themenblock anzulegen, halt über Nerds, Geeks und Co. um halt die ganze Kultur der Internetgeeks aufzurollen und mal zu sehen, was sie interessiert, wie sie funktionieren und so weiter und so fort.
Oh Gott, jetzt müssen wir dir wieder eine Frage stellen.
Ich glaube, ich hab das sogar in meiner Subscription-Liste drin. Vielleicht kannst du ja gleich mal nochmal die genaue URL von deinem Webblock sagen.
Das kannst du machen. Ansonsten, Thorsten, da wir ja kaum miteinander reden können, monologisiere es. Tolle Kommunikation, gefällt mir.
Sollten wir öfter machen, hat man Zeit zu überlegen. Pause, Pause, Pause.
Ihr habt Zeit zu überlegen, ich hab keine Zeit. Also, ich wollte vielleicht noch eine Sache anbringen, bevor ich doch auflege. Mobile Types hat zurzeit ein kleines Sicherheitsloch. Und zwar können Spammer die Comment-Funktion ausnutzen, um halt irgendwelche böse Mails zu versenden. Das wird die Zuhörer vielleicht interessieren. Die sollten sich mal eben ihre CGI's ansehen. Und auf Mobile Types Org ist auch ein kleiner Link. Der einem erklärt, was man abschalten muss.
Okay, diesen Link findet man natürlich auch auf www.schockwellenreiter.de, damit ich das mal loswerden kann.
Oh Gott, ich hab's noch nicht gelesen heute.
Ansonsten, Thorsten, danken wir dir erstmal so und erwarten jetzt auch nicht, dass du dich nochmal... Genau, genau, das dachte ich mir schon. Aber das war ja immer tolle Kommunikation. Vor allen Dingen deswegen, weil man ihn dann über die Gags, die wir gemacht haben, noch lachen hört, 30 Sekunden lang. Das ist schön. Weißt du, welches Log er meinte?
Ich hab dieses Nerds Real Life. Ah ja, genau. Also, wen das interessiert, das ist www.kleins mit z.net/nerds, also N-E-R-D-S. Und das ist in der Tat interessant zu lesen. Ja, jetzt sind wir selber ganz aus der Spur gekommen hier durch diese besondere Geschichte. Wo wollten wir denn...
Sowas passiert auch nur im Chaosradio, verstehst du?
Sicherheitsprobleme ist natürlich so ein Thema. Ja, aber was ich immer wieder sehr schön finde ist, jeder sucht sich hier wirklich sein Thema. Und das beglückt mich insofern, als dass das so auch eine alte Vision der Hacker tatsächlich mal unter Beweis stellt, dass das auch gekommen ist, so wie man das sich so schon immer gedacht hat, nämlich dass das Internet ein Kandidat ist, das Publishing für jeden zu ermöglichen.
Ja, nicht nur das Publishing. Ich bin also immer fasziniert und deswegen mache ich das Ganze ja auch, weil ich feststelle, also was für eine Menge an Kreativität freigesetzt wird, seitdem Leute, denen es relativ einfach ist im Internet zu publizieren, Bilder ins Netz zu stellen und so weiter und so fort. Ich habe da auch immer noch solche eine Idee. Es gab mal vor, da ist schon ewig lange her, ich will meinen Alltag jetzt nicht unbedingt verraten, eine Zeitung, die sich mit über Science Fiction beschäftigte, hochkarätig mit Science Fiction beschäftigte, die hatte in ihren besten Zeiten, die hieß Quarber Merkur, nach einem Ort in Österreich, Quarb, die hatte in ihren schlimmsten Zeiten 80 Leser, also 80 Abonnenten, das war irgendwann nicht mehr zu tragen, weil das eingestellt werden musste. So etwas ist etwas, was man unheimlich leicht dem Internet ohne großartige Kosten heute machen kann. Also es ist, man muss auch immer sehen, das Internet ist nicht nur ein Massenmedium. Also eine Publikation für 80 Leute hat ohne weiteres dort auch ihre Berechtigung. Und das ist eben halt etwas, was man gerade auch mit Webblog-Software relativ leicht und relativ schnell machen kann, ohne tatsächlich irgendwie erstmal großartig Programmierer oder HTML-Tagger sein zu müssen oder so. Man kann das tatsächlich irgendwie etwas ganz schnell machen. Man stellt es ins Netz. Und wie gesagt, die vorgefertigten Designs und so sind so schlimm auch nicht. Also man kann sie nehmen.
Und bevor wir jetzt, ich sehe schon wieder das Leuchten in Tims Augen, auf Trackback und ähnliches eingehen und halt die Spezialitäten das Ganze beleuchten, würde ich doch gerne mal so ein bisschen emotionaler werden, wenn wir heute Abend werden wollen. Und zwar, wenn ihr irgendwie schon mal was geschrieben habt oder ihr seid Blogger und ihr habt schon mal eine Geschichte veröffentlicht und sagt, da kam große Resonanz drauf oder so. Was habt ihr geschrieben und vor allen Dingen, wo sagt ihr, war wirklich große, große Leserresonanz, wo haben viele was dazugeschrieben, haben gesagt, hey, das war ein Thema, das hat echt gefallen oder damit hat dich erfolgt. Da haben viele bei Google mich besucht. Mich würde einfach mal interessieren, was sind so die Themen, die in den letzten zwei, drei Monaten gezogen haben, nach dem Motto, ich hab mal irgendwas geschrieben über, ich hab ein Bild vom neuen Mac oder so gefunden und zack, waren irgendwie so und so viele Leute auf meiner Seite oder ich hab meinen eigenen Code beschrieben und das wollten die Leute riechen, aber konnten sie das nur lesen? Was weiß ich, also wirklich, was wurde die Leute darauf abgegangsen? Das würde mich mal interessieren, weil Geschichten finde ich persönlich ja immer sehr spannend und da hoffe ich, dass ihr jetzt auch mal aus dem Klump kommt und es nicht bitte jetzt ins Webblog schreibt, sondern hier mal auch ein R erzählen. Ich weiß, es ist sehr ungewohnt. Ich erwarte jetzt mindestens fünf Geschichten und dann erst lassen wir den Tim die Trackback-Geschichte erzählen. Ich hoffe, ihr ruft jetzt zahlreich an. Würde mich sehr, sehr freuen. Der Christian ist am Telefon. Hallo Christian.
Hallo, grüß euch.
Aus Berlin.
Ja, ich wollte nur mal einen anderen Aspekt sagen von diesen Blogger-Webseiten, also ich bin Mediengestalter, dass ich persönlich glaube, das ist natürlich super für die Leute, die das nicht mit ihm programmieren können, aber von Ästhetischen her kommt ja eigentlich erst die eigene Persönlichkeit oder das Corporate Design zum Ausdruck, wenn Individualität da ist und wenn es so homogen ist, wenn mehrere Menschen die gleiche Webseite haben, ist ja auch nicht so toll. Also von daher denke ich, dass das schon gut ist, wenn man irgendwie einen guten Programmierer hat, der einen nach der eigenen Persönlichkeit auch dann berät und die Seite so gestaltet.
Das ist natürlich jetzt sehr feudal, seinen eigenen Programmierer zu halten, der einem dann das Webblock so gestaltet. Die meisten sind zu faul, überhaupt nur in Eintracht zu schreien.
Ich meine einfach, dass diese Firmen auch eine Menge Programmierer, die sowieso schon überflüssig sind, weil der Bedarf eigentlich gut gesättigt ist, arbeitslos sind. Und das heißt, die wenigen Leute, die noch am Start sind, wenn man denen jetzt durch so eine preisgünstigen Seiten, Blockbausätze und so weiter auch noch die Jobs wegschnappt, ist ja auch nicht so toll. Also von daher, ich meine, okay, das ist ein finanzieller Aspekt, aber meine ich das schon, echte Seiten, die haben einfach was. Und vor allen Dingen ist es auch ein bisschen interessanter, wenn eine Animation bei ist, zum Beispiel Flash oder vielleicht Begab.
Das war's Schalke. Bist du selber Blogger auch oder gar nicht?
Ich bin keiner.
Nein, ich hab drei Webseiten handprogrammiert.
Ich bin ja, wie gesagt, Mediengestalter.
Ja gut, ne, dann nehmen wir das einfach mal den Designhinweis mit. Wobei ich hoffe, dass sich vielleicht jetzt ein oder zwei Blogger melden, die dann auch mal über ihr Design reden. Weil viele geben sich dabei sehr, sehr viel Mühe. Muss man einfach mal sagen. Es gibt viele, die sehr, sehr viel Zeit drauf verwenden. Es gibt welche, die ihr Design fast alle zwei Monate tauschen. Die da wirklich drauf Wert legen, dass man es dann überhaupt nicht mehr wiedererkennt, wenn man auf die Seite kommt, der nicht wiedererkennungswert sozusagen. Christian, vielen Dank für deinen Anruf.
Du bist ja auch nicht schlecht mit deinem Weblog. Ich finde das ganz hübsch.
Ist aber sehr einfach.
Ist einfach, ja, aber die einfachen Sachen finde ich immer besonders bestechend. Was kann man da sagen?
Ich hatte wirklich, grün war so eine beruhigende Farbe. Ich wollte, dass wenn ich auf mein eigenes Weblog gehe, dass ich mich dann gut fühle. Und grün ist ja die Hoffnung, in der Kunsthistorischen, diese ganze Farblehre. Grün ist die Hoffnung. Und da dachte ich, grün, das muss auch so rüberkommen. Wobei man da auch wieder ein Problem hat, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen. Weil wenn du es auf dem Windows-PC anguckst, auf einem Mac oder auf einem Linux-Rechner, je nach Browser, je nach Monitor, ist es manchmal so ein Atommüllgrün. Und manchmal ist es so ein, oh, hier ist der Waldgrün. Insofern hat das nicht so ganz funktioniert, wie ich mir das gedacht hab. Aber wo wir schon mal dabei sind, Tim, dein Weblog ist ja auch unheimlich schön.
Das ist total hässlich. Ich benutze immer noch so einen Standard-Dingsbums und bin bis zum heutigen Tag noch nicht drauf gekommen, was ich eigentlich will. In meiner Optik deswegen arbeite ich so lange damit erstmal nochmal weiter. Aber glaubt man nicht, dass das bei mir nicht schon die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund ist, weil ich eigentlich auch so ein CSS-Hangspin. Ich hab allerdings an der Uni jetzt auch so ein Weblog-Projekt gestartet, wo ich das Ganze eben auch als leer unterstützendes Experiment sehe. So einerseits, um sozusagen auch Gestalter dazu zu bringen, da mit vergleichbaren Code-Basen eben Unterschiede herauszuarbeiten und eben auch diese persönlichen Note zu entwickeln. Auf der anderen Seite eben auch einfach als unterrichtsunterstützende Maßnahme. Also auch hier unser geliebter Dave Weiner. Ist ja jetzt halt dieser texanische Weblog. Ich sag jetzt mal nicht Papst, aber er ist umstritten. Bleiben wir erstmal so weit. Tatsache ist, er ist ja auch sehr umtriebig und ist jetzt irgendwie... An die Harvard-Uni gerufen worden, um dort eben die Webblogs auch zu verbreiten. Ich weiß nicht, zum Einsatz zu bringen. Was der jetzt konkret macht, habe ich so im Detail nicht verfolgt. Hast du da mal einen Blick drauf geworfen?
Es reicht, Scripty News zu lesen und dann ist...
Ich halte es als eine sehr große Hilfe, um eben auch so einen Lehrbetrieb zu unterstützen. Weil es einfach auch, wenn man die Studenten dazu animiert, ihren eigentlichen Lernprozess auch zu kommentieren über solche Webblogs, über Schritte, Sachen, die man herausgefunden und gefunden hat, das da drüber wieder rum zu postulieren, dann hat man eben auch diesen gegenseitigen Lerneffekt, der bei diesen isolierten Lernbedingungen, die an Universitäten nicht selten existieren, dann auch wiederum eine Nähe schafft, die sonst nicht da ist.
Das hat um 2000 Christia schon an der Universität Weimar probiert mit einem Projekt, wo er eben halt dann auch, ich glaube, das waren sogar Gestalter und Designer damals ans Netz ranführen wollte und hat dort an der Universität Weimar einen Manida-Server hochgezogen. Und das waren tatsächlich so mit die ersten deutschen, deutschsprachigen Weblogs. Also so weit wie ich wusste gab es sonst nur in Österreich schon einige. Und die an der Universität Weimar damals an diesem Seminar waren die ersten deutschsprachigen hier. Das waren die ersten, über die ich dann gestolpert bin, wie ich angefangen habe. Es gab noch ein paar Manidas-Sites, die so Manidas-Sites hatten, wie ich sie hatte. Aber selbst die aus Deutschland publizierten zu dem Zeitpunkt noch in Englisch. Sie trauten sich also noch nicht so richtig irgendwie. Sie trauten dem eigenen Markt noch nicht so.
Wobei das doch so ein bisschen die Verbindung ist. Also da schubbern sich so ein bisschen diese beiden Prinzipien. Du hast vorhin das Wiki erwähnt, dass gerade für so Lernumgebungen, das Anhäufen von Wissen in so einem Internetbereich natürlich in so einer lexikalischen Form nicht gerade schlecht ist. Dass es eben auf sich selber verweist, dann der andere hat das Projekt, der hat das so versucht, schau mal hier und so weiter. Da ist so ein Wiki natürlich auch nicht falsch.
Aber ein Wiki hab ich auch schon probiert.
Das hat nicht geklappt.
Also was ich mir ja wünsche ist ja eine Webblog Software, die beides verbindet. Also die Wiki Prinzipien wie auch die Webblog Prinzipien. Manila war damals dabei. Also es war nicht schlecht. Sie hatten so etwas ähnliches, dass also so automatische Links generierte, wenn man also bestimmte Shortcuts reinsetzte. Es gibt dann auch noch dieses Vanilla von Christian Langreiter aus Österreich, das in Rebol programmiert ist, dass eigentlich eine Kombination zwischen Webblog und Wiki tatsächlich komplett ist, dass die kompletten Wiki-Dinger drin hat. Und es gibt da noch ein Vanilla-Klon, der Snip-Snap heißt, der das drin hat.
Das ist in Java geschrieben?
Das ist in Java geschrieben. Ich glaube, dass sogar das hier Berlin kommt. Das wäre in beiden Fällen, ich würde es sonst schon längst eingesetzt. Rebol wie auch Java sind mir etwas Programmiersprachen, die ich nicht so gerne anfasse. Deswegen habe ich das sein lassen. Aber ich stütze jetzt z.B. CoreBlock, das ist von einem japanischen Programmierer, das setzt auf Zoab auf. Und der hat auch versprochen, Wiki-Sachen einzusetzen.
Damit du es dir richtig schwierig gemacht hast, natürlich nur mit einer japanischen Anleitung.
Das Ding hat leider nur eine japanische Anleitung. Aber ich treffe mich morgen mit jemanden und wir wollen ein deutschsprachiges Dokumentationsprojekt für CoreBlock aufsetzen.
Lüblich.
Ich kenne auch noch eine Webseite, da kann ich gleich mal feinen lassen, wo wir so schön am Oris runter erzählen. Das ist eine schöne Programmierer-Webseite, die heißt decafbad, D-E-C-A-F-B-A-D. Die Eingeweihten würden es sofort erkennen als eine Hexadizimalzahl, die aber im Prinzip irgendwie kein Koffein ist schlecht, ausdrückt. Und auch da hat er es geschafft, so ein Movable-Type zusammenzubringen mit dem Twiki-System, die wir übrigens auch unter wiki.cc.de benutzen.
Jetzt sind wir fast schon wieder bei Trackback, was ich eigentlich vermeiden wollte. Ich hab das nicht gesagt, du redest die ganze Zeit davon. Ja, das ist auch nur so ein Überbegriff für das Böse. Deswegen möchte ich euch mitten anzurufen. 0331 77 97 110. Sonst drehen mir die Jungs hier ab. Der Daniel aus Düsseldorf ist am Telefon. Hallo, Daniel.
Ja, hallo, Grüße an alle. Jörg weiß dann Bescheid. Ich würd ganz gern, vielleicht kann Jörg noch mal...
Daniel aus Düsseldorf hat schon gereicht.
Ja, wohnen in AC, aber ist grad platt. Also Movable-Type immer mit Datenbank betreiben ist sicherer. Vielleicht kann Jörg noch mal was dazu sagen. Also zum Aspekt, man hat ja schon gewisse Corp-Logger, sprich Industrial Technology etc. und die Antwill-Leute und so. Also dass Informationen auch relativ schnell rumgereicht werden und auch je nachdem, wie man sich einbringt, natürlich auch die Informationsdichte relativ schnell sehr hoch ist. Also dass dieser Community-Gedanke vielleicht nochmal angesprochen wird.
Das kannst du ja auch einfach mal machen.
Also Community bin ich glaube ich auch nicht so der richtige Ansprechpartner. Ich bezeichne mich ja selber immer als völlig community incompatibel. Das ist nicht unbedingt mein Thema. Vielleicht erzählst du wirklich besser da mal was.
Ja, also ich musste einfach feststellen, dass wenn man brav die Blogs liest und auch schön per Newsaggregator verfolgt, dass man relativ schnell auch in einer gewissen Szene drin ist und sich natürlich auch gegenseitig die Kommentare reinhaut. Und dass das Ganze unabhängig von dem Link abladen auch natürlich sehr viel Spaß macht. Man bekommt direkt Feedback, man kann Sachen diskutieren. Informationen werden sehr schnell rumgereicht. Und das Ganze ist auf jeden Fall ein sehr großer Vorteil zu den ganzen statischen HTML-Geschichten, die wir jetzt jahrelang hatten. Und stellt, finde ich, einen großen Vorteil von den Blogs auch da.
Ja, das ist natürlich richtig. Und da macht das einen großen Spaß dann, wenn wir schon in Düsseldorf sind, kann man ja auch gleich weiter nach Köln gehen zu industrialtechnologyandwitchcraft.de. Da vermute ich das Webblog mit der längsten URL der Welt. Die regelrechte Kommentarpartys feiern im Senfkeller. Und das macht natürlich Spaß, das ist richtig.
Ja, vielleicht könnt ihr nochmal die RSS-Geschichte auch nochmal hören. Ich mein, sitzen ja doch relativ viele Leute...
Ja, wenn wir schon längst, wenn sich Max nicht so dagegen gewährt, schätzt er sich auf die Technik an.
Die haben es erst 23.18. Es hören ganz junge Leute zu.
Ja, aber gut, dass du uns darauf hinweist. Ich halte es auch für wichtig, da kommen wir auch gleich nochmal drauf zu. Aber ich wollte auch nochmal was dazu sagen, was du sagst. Ich denke, dass ein großer Vorteil der Blogosphäre, jetzt haben wir den tollen Begriff nochmal fallen gelassen, der ist einerseits halt dieses, man kennt sich, aber auf der anderen Seite auch, glaube ich, auch ein bisschen getrieben durch diese Vertrautheit, ein hoher Anteil an Meinungen und, naja, Besämpfung ist ein schöner ITW-Begriff. Also einfach nicht nur die Information als solche rauszutun, geschweige denn diese bewusste neutrale Zurückhaltung, die der Journalismus in der Regel ja für sich in Anspruch nimmt, zu tragen, sondern eben ganz bewusst auch mit Meinungen oder mindestens mit Beimängungen zu arbeiten, sodass man eben neben der Information auch immer noch gleich den Smiley sieht und weiß, ob er in die eine oder andere Richtung zeigt. Und das hilft einem natürlich auch sehr, da mitzumachen. Und wenn man halt so seine Leute auch kennt, so ich meine auch, du bist in meinem RSS-Rieder, dann weiß man eben auch, wer findet was eigentlich jetzt interessant, wer liest wen, wer kennt wen und ja, man kennt sich.
Ja, ich denke, das ist auch nochmal eine interessante Geschichte dabei, dass man, wo sich so etwas ausweitert, weil fast alle Webblogs haben ja irgendwo rechts oder links auf der Seite eine Liste der Webblogs, die sie regelmäßig lesen.
Die sogenannte Blog-Roll.
Die Blog-Roll und über diese Blog-Roll kommt man dann, also sozusagen über die eigene Blog-Roll und dann über die Blog-Roll der Webblogs, die man regelmäßig liest, entsteht es durch eine Art Wolke. Innendrin ist so ein kompakter Kern und nach außen fasert das so ein bisschen aus, die ja schon so tatsächlich auch vielleicht so etwas wie eine Community bietet oder so etwas zumindestens. Also man hat so Interessen, die Interessen überschneiden sich und was es natürlich bringt, weil du das vorhin angesprochen hast, es bringt natürlich tatsächlich so, dass sich Informationen rasend schnell verbreiten. Also wenn ich etwas poste, dann geht das sozusagen erstmal in die Leute, die mich in ihrer engeren Blockrolle haben und diese Blockrollen überschneiden sich zwar, aber sie sind eben nicht identisch. Das heißt, es geht dann also darüber weiter, darüber weiter und darüber weiter.
Epidemisch.
Sehr schönes Wort. Und so breiten sich eben halt Informationen sehr schnell aus. Manchmal allerdings auch falsche Informationen. Das darf man nicht vergessen. Das stimmt.
Ja, aber wir wissen ja sowieso, dass das, was die Zeitung schreiben kann, mittlerweile auch nicht mehr für bare Münzen nehmen. Deswegen, du bist doch einer, der immer gerne schreibt, schreibt, der Tagesspiegel ist also wahr. Und das lacht immer schon so dermaßen, dass man weiß, natürlich ist das wahrscheinlich wieder nicht wahr, beziehungsweise wir fragen uns, ob das wahr ist. Und das muss man ja generell tun. Insofern kann man uns ja wieder beruhigt lesen, was da steht.
Ja, das ist schon richtig.
Muss man sich immer fragen, generell. Auch bei dem, was man selber schreibt.
Ist das überhaupt wahr? Beziehungsweise war das überhaupt wahr?
Ja, aber das ist auch wieder die, die wir vorhin schon mal hatten, in der Diskussion, dass eben halt auch mit zunehmender Bekanntheit, mit zunehmendem Bekanntheitsgrad, man doch schon sorgfältiger mit den Informationen umgehen muss.
Hast du da schon mal Ärger gehabt, zum Beispiel, wo einer gesagt hat, Herr Kantl, das stimmt aber so nicht.
Ich bin mal, und das glaube ich auch zu Recht, von, damit wir wieder mal eine URL fallen lassen können, von www.worldwaldklein.de, also von Konstantin Klein, also ziemlich böse und zu Recht angemacht worden, dass sich eine Information, das ging damals um diese Kantlberg hießen die, also um diesen Jungen, der angeblich von Neonazis in irgendeinem Ort plattgemacht worden ist. Und die Geschichte aber war ein völliger Fake dann dabei. Ich konnte mich also natürlich damit irgendwie ein bisschen beruhigen, darin auch so ziemlich sämtliche Zeitungen in der Spiegel vorne ran raufgefallen. Aber er hat mich eben halt angestoßen und hat gesagt, man sollte ein bisschen auf seine, ein bisschen Grundjournalistische Sorgfaltspflicht schon reinbringen. Und seitdem versuche ich das zumindest immer. Ich meine, man braucht das nicht zu machen, wenn man also den neuesten, die das neueste Software Update verkündet, was ich ja sehr viele in diesem Falle mache. Ob das wahr ist oder nicht wahr ist, ist relativ egal. Aber wenn man solche politischen Sachen aufgreift, die ich ja nun auch relativ häufig drin habe, da bin ich dadurch auch mittlerweile nicht mehr so schnell, wie ich früher war, weil ich die Sachen doch, bevor ich sie veröffentliche, gegenchecke. Und vor allen Dingen mache ich das in dem Bereich, wo ich immer auch schreibe, wir nennen Ross und Reiter, also wo ich Spammer veröffentliche und so. Die werden von mir, die ich da veröffentliche, werden tatsächlich von mir vorher angeschrieben und sollen eine Stellungnahme abgeben. Und erst wenn ich dann die üblichen wüsten Beschimpfungen zurückkriege, in dem Moment sage ich dann, okay, das waren sie tatsächlich. Weil hier natürlich auch oft mit gefälschten Absenderadressen gearbeitet wird und ähnliches. Wo man dann also tatsächlich sorgfältiger arbeiten muss, als man das eigentlich ursprünglich mal vorhatte.
Wo du das gerade ansprichst, da ist ja noch so eine schöne Zweitseite, die schönste Spam-Zusammenfassung, die ich kenne, die Nigeria Connection. Jeder kennt es sicherlich, wer schon mal seine Spam auch gelesen hat. Regelmäßig gibt es da diesen Anschrieb von... Mobutu, genau, die irgendwie den großen Finanzplan am Start haben.
Veröffentlicht sind dort ungefähr 650 verschiedene Briefe. Ich habe aber noch eine riesige Backlist von ungefähr 3000, die noch nicht drin sind. Weil, nachdem das auch durch die Presse gegangen ist, schicken wir sehr viele Leute auch diese Briefe zu. Und ich muss da jetzt dringend mal wieder was machen, weil ich jetzt so schöne bekomme von Schwiegervätern, von Saddam Hussein oder ähnlichen Geschichten. Die sind auch wieder relativ hitze. Ich hab's da gemacht, weil ich die einfach irgendwie als so eine Art Folklore sehe, diese Dinger, egal wie sie auch sind. Und ich hab mir irgendwie mal gedacht, okay, Trikot veröffentlicht die Lieder der Mafia. Und ich veröffentliche eben halt die Briefe der Nigeria Connection.
Daniel, was veröffentlicht du denn so, wenn deine Datenbank nicht gerade abgeräuscht ist, nur damit alle anderen mal Eindruck haben? Was du so schreibst?
Ja, am Anfang halt links. Also ausgelöst wurde der ganze Kram eigentlich auch ein schönes Thema durch ein Rollwerk. Also sprich, dass wir Irak-Krieg hatten und irgendwie man seine Meinung, seine Emotionen loswerden wollte. Und das war eigentlich so der primäre Auslöser, dass ich gesagt hab, irgendwie jetzt reicht's irgendwie. Ich will da zu was sagen. Dann über den normalen Link-Dump, dass man Sachen halt ablegt. Und ja, mittlerweile tendiere ich dazu, wenn das Ding dann am 1. Dezember wieder neu anläuft, mich auf ein Thema zu spezialisieren. Also doch nicht ganz soweit, weniger persönliche Erfahrung eher inhaltlich für mich selber, die Suchfunktion zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und was soll das für ein Spezialbereich werden?
Ich wollte mich halt mit Medien auch beschäftigen. Also eine gute Adresse ist auch Binary is not that. Also sprich Medienkunst, Medienkritik, Netzkultur. Da Telepolis ja da ein bisschen am Losen ist momentan, da haben wir ein bisschen wieder...
Binary is not that dot was?
Ja, aber dann wollte ich noch ganz kurz darauf hinweisen für die Hörer vielleicht draußen. Also hier Moe, Plastic Thinking Org, ist ja auch sehr aktiv und er hat ein wunderbares Wiki, wo also alle Systeme aufgeführt werden, Erklärungen dazu. Müsste unter webblog.plastic-thinking-org-wiki erreichbar sein.
Das ist auf jeden Fall unter plastic-thinking-org.de, da ist ein Button drauf, Plastic Wiki. Die URL hab ich jetzt auch nicht in Kopf.
Er ist auch sehr aktiv momentan, was Politik in Webblogs angeht. Also diese irgendwelche Demos in Gießen oder so, da sind die die ganze Zeit am Berichten und live und etc. Ist auch ein netter Aspekt.
Und er führt auch ein Webblog gegen Studiengebühren in Hessen.
Wobei man sagen muss, daran merkt man, dass es halt noch nicht so ganz in der Populärkultur angekommen ist, dass es halt immer noch Internetadressen sind, für die man fast einen Doktor braucht. Also das ist immer so.hm,.bla,.bla,.org, slash. Und dann kommt noch mal eine Rattenschwanz.
Aber lange URL sind komischerweise da sehr beliebt. Und man hat da wenig Probleme mit. Zumal es eh etwas ist, was man einmal in seine Bookmarks oder in seinen RSS-Räder nehmen kann. Sicherlich, wenn wir mich nicht daran hin, dass noch erklären werden, dann geht das halt alles schon. Und es ist auch wiederum mal so eine eigene Kunst, wie man ja auch sicherlich an unserer Sprache schon gut merken kann, dass diese Blogosphäre, ich liebe dieses Wort, auch schon wieder seinen eigenen Slang hervorbringt. Also das Posten oder so, das ist ja noch harmlos, aber so die Blogroll und all das, was damit zu tun hat. Ich hab's mir jetzt gar nicht aufgeschrieben, den Slang, aber da kann man ja fast noch meine eigene Sendung machen.
Der kommt bei dir doch fast wie von selber, Junge.
Ich hab irgendwann mal eine tolle Chaosradio gemacht über Computer und Hacker-Slang. Das war eigentlich sehr ergiebig.
War das nicht mit Buzzword Bingo, wo ich dann irgendwie Süßigkeiten gekriegt hab, wenn ich nicht eine Reihe voll hatte? Naja, ich weiß, das ist ja wirklich... Dann lass uns doch mal über RSS sprechen, weil da haben wir jetzt die ganze Zeit schon angedeutet, weil das ist, finde ich, das ist durch die Webblogs groß geworden, wenn man so will, aber mittlerweile haben viele, viele Newsseiten das auch in ihrem Angebot und ist eigentlich die geilste Art, das Internet zu lesen, weil wenn ich das nicht hab, das wird auch der Grund, dass ich mich da nicht drum kümmere, wenn ich nicht das Richtige an meinem Rechner habe. Das geht schnell. Das ist einfach geil.
Tatsächlich ist die Herkunft genau andersrum. Angefangen hat es eigentlich mit dem Bedarf von diesen Portalen. Nur erinnerst dich, Portale waren mal so eine der Sachen, von denen alle glaubten, das wäre jetzt der große Hype. Einige populäre Dienste haben sich mit diesem Portalding dann auch komplett in den Fuß geschossen. Ich sag nur Alter Vista, die irgendwann ihre Homepage, die mal klein und schlank und rank war, so lange mit irgendwie Portalscheiße zugehauen haben, bis alle nur noch Google benutzen wollten. Davon haben sie sich nie wieder erholt. Aber generell ist natürlich auch ein Portal sinnvoll. Kommt halt nur drauf an, was drin steht, wenn es nicht immer nur dpa und cnn ist. Sprich, es gab den Bedarf, die Headlines von anderen Nachrichtenprovidern sehr einfach einzubinden. Dafür bräuchte man einen technischen Standard, da sind verschiedene Sachen ausprobiert worden.
Es fing an mit dem sogenannten RSS-09, das ist von NetScap entwickelt worden, für das NetScap-eigene Portal. Und dann hat der schon mehrmals, dessen Namen hier schon mehrmals gefallen, der Definer, hat das aufgenommen. Und für seine damalige Webblog-Software, nämlich Manila in der Hauptsache, dann ein Format entwickelt RSS001. Er hat es im Prinzip nur ein klein wenig weiterentwickelt. Das interessante an diesem Format ist, es ist also reines XML. Das heißt, es ist nur eine reine Auszeichnung, und zwar eine semantische Auszeichnung, ohne den ganzen Designs-Schnickschnack. Und es ist nur Text. Und das macht es unheimlich schnell. Es bekommt also unheimlich schnell über das Internet irgendwo hin. Es wird tatsächlich auch über HTTP übertragen. Das heißt, es kommt auch durch Firewalls durch, was ja auch nochmal eine wichtige Rolle spielt dann dabei. Und dann braucht man aber natürlich dann, es kann eben dadurch nicht mehr im Browser angezeigt werden. Das ist das andere dann dabei. Man braucht sogenannte spezielle Reader. Also Tim hat das vorhin schon ein paar Mal erwähnt, die das dann anzeigen. Und sehr viele Webblock-Software stürzen sich sehr schnell da drauf und die boten das dann automatisch an, dass also wer ein Webblock betreibt, dann auch automatisch ein RSS-Feed raus holt. Und dieser RSS-Feed, den kann man dann abonnieren. Und man kann dann also, ich habe, ich weiß nicht, ich abonniere glaube ich 500 RSS-Feeds dann dabei und habe dann also die Möglichkeit, sehr schnell in einem, in dem von mir benutzten Reader, das ist NetNews via Lite, dann also sehr schnell einen Überblick zu haben, was sind denn die neuen Nachrichten, die Nachrichten des Tages dann dabei, um dann eben auch zu überlegen, wie konzipiere ich heute meinen Blog, was setze ich rein und was mache ich so. Das heißt, also 500 Webblocks kann ich nicht lesen, aber 500 RSS-Feeds in meinen Reader rein und dann die mal eben an einem Rutsch durchzublättern. Das geht eben halt. Und das ist dann immer die Möglichkeit, so etwas sehr schnell zu machen.
Für diejenigen, die sich das jetzt gar nicht vorstellen können, trotz der Ausführungen, das ist dann halt nicht mehr die Webseite besuchen, sondern man hat seinen Teil und das ist im Grunde wie E-Mails, gestaffelte E-Mails lesen und man sieht die Headline von dieser E-Mail, die im Grunde das ist, was da als Nachricht auf der Newsseite auch erscheint. Man bleibt aber die ganze Zeit in diesem Programm und kann halt 500 Seiten durchgehen, einfach in einem Stream runtergucken. Es geht halt ratzfatz und man muss nicht warten, bis irgendwas lädt oder ähnliches, sondern das passiert alles im Hintergrund. Das macht es halt unglaublich komfortabel. Und dementsprechend verliert man nicht so schnell die Lust, wenn man nach 10 oder 15 Seiten nichts gefunden hat, sondern man macht dann noch relativ gerne weiter.
Es gibt auch für die Leute, die jetzt, also es gibt verschiedene Programme, also für Macintosh zu empfehlen, schon genannt, NetNewsWire, ranchero.com/netnewswire. Sehr schönes Programm, auch kostenlos in der einfachen Version.
Hast du gesagt, dass es für Mac ist?
Ja, für Windows habe ich nicht persönlich so viel mehr Erfahrung, aber von dem, was mir berichtet wurde, ist FeedReader, auch eine entsprechend kostenlose und ähnlich einfach aufgebaute Variante für die Leute, die jetzt eh keinen eigenen Computer haben, sondern primär so das Web benutzen, aber auch vielleicht Webblogs folgen wollen. Gibt es auch Webdienste, die sozusagen diese RSS-Lesefunktion anbieten. bloglines.com ist eine dieser Angebote.
Ja und wer natürlich alles zusammen haben will, also Webblog-Software und FeedReader, der kann Radio Userland nehmen, das gibt es für Windows und für den Macintosh. Das hat dann auch die Vorteile, dass es direkt integriert ist. Man liest seinen RSS-Feed, drückt auf einem Knopf und sofort steht das Ganze im Webblog. Das geht auch. Also das ist die komfortabelste Versicherung. Radio Userland kostet 99 Dollar.
Aber einmal nur kaufen?
Nein, das ist eine Jahreslizenz im Prinzip. Man muss aber die Jahreslizenz nicht verlängern, man kann dann die Software weiter benutzen, aber man kriegt dann keine neuen Updates mehr.
Jutti, wir werden das auch gleich noch mal zusammenfassen. Es gibt so ein paar Seiten, wo man dann die Infos auch etwas gebündelt. Da findet Vorher machen wir aber erst mal Nachrichten.
Wenn Fritz-Infiten sinken, dann 100 2, 6.
Wir haben es 23 Uhr 33.
Fritz-Info.
Mit dem Wetter in der Nacht bewölkt sich es immer mehr. Ab und zu gibt es Regen, die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 4 Grad. Morgen ist es vormittags noch regnerisch, später dann ein bisschen freundlicher, bei maximal 9 bis 11 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Dörner.
Der Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und Bundesrat hat seine Beratungen auf den 10. Dezember vertagt. Eine Stunde lang hatten Vertreter von Regierung und Opposition nach Kompromissen bei den geplanten Reformen gesucht. Beide Seiten sprachen danach von tiefgreifenden Meinungsverschiedenheiten in der Steuer- und Arbeitsmarktpolitik. Aus Protest gegen Kürzung im Bildungsetat haben Studenten die PDS-Zentrale in Berlin besetzt. Die PDS teilte mit, sie betrachte die Studenten als ihre Gäste. Für morgen Mittag planen Studenten aller drei Berliner Universitäten eine Demonstration vom Potsdamer Platz zum Roten Rathaus. Die umstrittene Embryonenforschung wird auch künftig nicht mehr mit EU-Geldern gefördert. Die Forschungsminister der Europäischen Union lehnten einen entsprechenden Vorstoß der Kommission ab. Israelische Soldaten haben am Abend im Süden des Gazastreifens drei Palästinenser erschossen. Der Vorfall wurde unterschiedlich dargestellt. Nach israelischen Angaben wollten die Männer eine jüdische Siedlung angreifen. Palästinenser sagten dagegen, es habe sich um unbewaffnete Zivilisten gehandelt, die auf dem Weg zu einer Feier waren. Und zum Sport in der Fußball Champions League hat der VfB Stuttgart vorzeitig das Achtelfinal erreicht. Die Stuttgarter gewannen am Abend gegen die Glasgow Rangers mit 1 zu 0. In der Basketball Euro League hat Alba Berlin den ersten Sieg geschafft. Die Berliner bezwangen den spanischen Club Tau Vitorio mit 95 zu 89. Ja, und der Verkehr auf Rütz, der hat keine Meldung, deswegen gute Fahrt.
Noch bis zum Freitag. Mit Freikarten. Für Travis am Donnerstag. Und Craig David am Freitag. Und die Karten bringt wie immer der Fritz Karpensberg. Noch bis zum Freitag. Unser Radio.
Dann mal ist dein Musikvorrat erschöpft oder was?
Nö, das ist nur gerade so eine kleine Kreativpause, würde ich sagen.
Toll eingesetzt.
Hatten wir ja nun auch gerade, ne? Wo waren wir denn? Wir waren, ah ich weiß, wo wir waren.
Ich erzähl dir erstmal noch mal, wo wir sind, bevor wir sagen, wo wir waren. Oh, genau. Wir sind nämlich bei Fritz und ihr hört das Chaosradio, immer am letzten Mittwoch im Monat. Das heißt Chaosradio, weil es immer etwas chaotischer hergeht. Da sind wir aber auch stolz drauf. Heute Abend geht es um ein Thema, was vielleicht nicht jedem was sagt, was aber durchaus spannend ist und euch vielleicht inspirieren könnte, nämlich das Thema. Und ich sage jetzt nicht zuerst Webblogs, ich sage zuerst Blogosphäre. Und den Begriff Blogosphäre kann Kollege Tim Pritlove oder auch heute Abend möchte er Pritlove genannt werden, vom Chaos Computer Club vielleicht nochmal mit Leben füllen, bevor er das Handtuch weiter gibt an Jörg Cantle vom Shockwellenrader, der auch im Studio ist, genauso wie ich, Max. Blogosphäre, Tim.
Danke, Blogosphäre, Max. Blogosphäre ist die selbst gewählte Bezeichnung aller der Leute, die Webblogs schreiben und Webblogs lesen und sich darin sehr wohlfühlen und untereinander sich Informationen über das Web austauschen. Ist eigentlich eine recht persönliche Angelegenheit, insofern als dass eben viele Leute ihre Nachrichtenveröffentlichungen eben selbst alleine schreiben. Ein Mann, eine Website. Viele Leute das aber lesen.
Es gibt auch Webseiten und Webblogs. Das hört sich auch gut an. Das hört sich irgendwie vor dem Untergang der Zitane.
Jetzt kriegen wir wahrscheinlich wieder Ärger mit den Mädchen. Aber so war es ja nicht gemeint. Das bringt mich übrigens auch auf den Punkt, dass es sehr wohl auch Webblogs gibt, die eben von mehreren Leuten gepflegt werden. Ein gutes Beispiel haben wir dann hier schon wieder sitzen. Du bist ja für alles fast ein gutes Beispiel. Aber du fast. Mit dem Rollberg, was ich auch ein schönes Projekt finde. Vielleicht magst du das mal selber noch kurz anreißen, bevor wir dann auch wieder kurz noch mal auf die...
Ja, also erstmal der Rollberg ist eine Website, die von mehreren Leuten gefüllt wird. Die ist sogar älter als mein eigenes Webblog. Die war immer schon von Anfang an als etwas gedacht, was von mehreren betrieben wird. Es ist aber mittlerweile eine Art Webblog geworden und zurzeit sind, glaube ich, 15 Leute mehr oder weniger aktiv dabei. Und das sollte immer so etwas sein, was also andere Nachrichten verbreitet. Es hatte einen sehr großen Erfolg. Erfolg ist ganz schlecht in dem Zusammenhang zu sagen, aber wie am 11.9. die Maschinen in den Twin Tower gerast sind und also die gesamte Internet Nachrichten Struktur zusammengebrochen war, da habe ich halt, da ich am Institut, wo ich arbeite, auf einer fetten Leitung noch sitze und noch an Informationen rankam, habe ich diese Informationen da reingezogen und da dann ins Web gestellt und da habe ich dann auch irgendwie gemerkt, dass sowas auch eine Möglichkeit ist, also Informationen zu bringen, die sonst nicht überall stehen oder auch Informationen zu bündeln, was er ja momentan eher macht als neue Informationen zu bringen, die nicht überall stehen. Und darum habe ich ihn wieder aktiviert zu der Zeit des Irak-Krieges. Das war ja vorhin schon mal angesprochen worden. Ich hatte ihn zu dem Zeitpunkt, der war ein bisschen eingeschlafen, ich hatte ihn zu diesem Zeitpunkt wieder aktiviert, weil es irgendwie überall sonst eher eine Meldung gab, die in solch einem Einheitsbrei landeten. Und wir dann doch wollten, dass man zumindest auch die Meldungen bringt, die eben nicht gerade dem amerikanischen Präsidenten zujubeln.
Also alternatives Informationsquellen-Ding im Grunde. Bevor wir jetzt aber weitermachen mit RSS, können wir gleich noch ein bisschen drüber reden, möchten wir erstmal mit euch widersprechen. 0317797110. Schließlich ist das eure Sendung und ihr sollt auch mitreden können. Und ich hoffe, dass der Roland noch am Telefon ist.
Hallo, Roland.
Ist das vielleicht einfach nur die Seite? Eine Sekunde muss man etwas ausprobieren. Ich rede jetzt natürlich Bullshit, aber Hallo, Roland. Roland, die kleine Maus ist nicht mehr da.
Schade. Hallo, Dominik.
Also nicht ein Tag heute, nicht wirklich mein Tag.
Dominik, was ist denn heute am Gehen hier?
Sie müssen die richtige Taste drücken. Sie müssen die richtige Taste drücken.
Ich wohne in diesem verfluchten Studien.
Weißt du noch, wo der Kühlschrank ist?
Ja, ich weiß, wo der Kühlschrank ist. Warte mal ganz kurz. Dominik? Irgendwie hat dieses Ding heute auf mich abgesehen. Das Problem ist, hier gibt es nur zwei Knöpfe. Ich halte mich schon für völlig ruhig. Jetzt will er nicht mehr, hat der Dominik gesagt.
Nee, wir haben ihn gehört, aber er hat noch...
Also grundsätzlich möchte ich natürlich nicht die Technik hier verfluchen, aber irgendwie ist heute ein bisschen der Wurm drin. Ich hoffe, ihr meldet euch nochmal.
Schwache Ausrede. Dann kann ich ja doch noch ein bisschen über RSS-Rider berichten, oder ist noch jemand in der Warte?
Nee, erzähl erst mal. Ich werd mich jetzt mal hier um das Thema kümmern.
Wir hatten ja eben aufgehört bei diesen RSS-Ridern, entweder im Web oder eben als einfaches Programm, was man auf seinem eigenen Rechner einrichten kann. Genauso wie es eine Hilfe gibt, diese Webblogs zu lesen, gibt es auch Hilfen, diese Webblogs zu schreiben. Die meisten Webblogs kommen in der Regel mit einem Webinterface dahin, wo man schon recht einfach einen Eintrag hinzufügen kann. Noch sehr viel einfacher ist es, wenn man ein Programm hat, einen sogenannten Webblog Editor, der einem eben auch das Schreiben der Einträge auf dem Rechner erlaubt. Ich finde das gerade dann besonders angenehm, wenn man mit dem Laptop unterwegs ist, gerade gar kein Internet hat, also gar nicht die Möglichkeit hätte, in dem Moment was zu schreiben. Dann müsste man das ja sonst lokal vorschreiben und dann wieder eintragen. Das geht natürlich auch alles, aber es ist eben noch ein bisschen bequemer mit einem Programm, das das macht. Auch dieses NetNews Fire hat eine kommerzielle Version, also eine Bezahlversion, die das bietet. Und es gibt noch auch ein paar freie Programme, die das bieten. Das interessante daran ist, dass, obwohl es viele verschiedene Systeme da draußen gibt, wie man eben dieses Personal Publishing machen kann, sich schon der ein oder andere Standard durchsetzt, wie man eben mit einem Programm vom eigenen Computer, mit dem Webblog-System kommunizieren kann. Sogenannte APIs, die sich da ein bisschen durchsetzen. Das ist noch so ein evolutionärer Prozess, aber man sieht schon ganz klar, dass es dort auch den Willen gibt, was Neues zu schaffen. Unter anderem gibt es ja da auch gerade diese vielwellenschlagende Weiterentwicklung eines solchen Formats, wo man auch eigentlich ganz gut sehen kann, wie die Logosphäre so zusammenarbeitet in technischer Hinsicht. Ich fand das ganz interessant, das zu beobachten, von der Namensfindung bis zur breiten Diskussion der Features. Jetzt hat das Kind auch einen Namen und heißt... Atom, Atom. Ich weiß gar nicht, was war denn eigentlich der ausschlaggebende?
Das hieß zuerst Echo und es gab dann glaube ich rechtliche Gründe, also Echo wird in vielen Stellen benutzt und es gab dann eben rechtliche Gründe, dass sich irgendjemand beschwert hat, der schon an ältere Rechte an den Namen zu haben glaubte. Aber es ist schon richtig, diese APIs steht für Advanced Programming Interface. Das bedeutet, das ist eigentlich nur eine Schnittstelle, um eben halt die Daten von dem einen, also von irgendwoher auf das Weblog zu bringen. Als erste hatte Blogger einen API auf den Markt gebracht, weil die auch sehr erkannt haben. Das ist ja eigentlich der Ansatzpunkt dazu, dass das Browser Fenster doch manchmal ein etwas schwachbrüstiger Ersatz ist, wenn man etwas schreiben will dann dabei. Und im Prinzip sind die eben halt so definiert, dass man, wenn man programmieren kann, natürlich sich sozusagen auch in seiner Textverarbeitung hinsetzen kann und etwas schreiben. Und dann drückt man auf einen Knopf, das Programm liest das dann aus der Textverarbeitung heraus, wandelt das dann, soweit es das kann, in dieses API Format um, schickt dieses API Format an das Weblog, wo immer das auch liegen mag, und wupsch ist es auch wieder ein Weblog Eintrag dann dabei. Das erste API war wie gesagt das Blogger API. Das kannte aber nur zwei Sachen, nämlich Überschrift und Text, weil Blogger kannte zu dem Zeitpunkt auch nichts anderes. Man konnte nur Überschrift und Text eingeben dann dabei. Und dann gab es eben halt das Meta Weblog API, was also eine Weiterentwicklung des Blogger APIs war. Beide transportierten die Daten allerdings beide schon als XML, also in einem standardisierten Auszeichnungsformat, das auch wieder reiner Text ist und damit auch wieder durch sämtliche Firewalls kommt. Das Ganze hatten wir vorhin schon mal bei RSS dann dabei rüber. Mit diesem API waren dann einige wiederum unzufrieden. Und zwar mit beide, mit der RSS-Definition, wie auch mit dem Meta Webblog API. In beiden Fällen auch wieder eine gewisse Dominanz des Dave Weiner befürchtet wurde. Also der Name wird bestimmt nochmal öfter fallen dann dabei. Und das ist in der Hauptsache um einen, ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, ob es ein englischer oder amerikanischer Python Programmierer ist, Mark Pilgrim herum. Dive into Mark hat ja jedenfalls auch, heißt sein Webblock. Dive into Python ist ein fantastisches Online-Buch, kostenlos über Python, dass man sich dann auch, wenn man Englisch kann, mal runterziehen kann oder wenn man auch in Python programmieren will. Also ich ja auch nicht unbedingt weiß und nicht unbedingt jedermanns Sache ist. Jedenfalls um diesen Mark Pilgrim herum hat sich nochmal eine Community gebildet, die also an einem neuen API arbeitet. Dies heißt dann eben halt Atom oder Atom oder wie auch immer. Aber ich musste auch ehrlich sagen, wir haben es ja auch in der Vorbesprechung schon gehabt. So ganz blicke ich da noch nicht durch, ob es sich wirklich lohnt auf diesen Zug aufzuspringen. Also momentan bevorzuge ich noch eher das Metawedblock API und eben halt RDF RSS.
Da hast du der kleinste gemeinsame Nenner, der zumindest jetzt auch funktioniert. Das brauche auf jeden Fall noch seine Zeit, bis es sich...
Es ist zwar kein offizieller Standard, aber es ist so etwas wie ein inoffizieller Standard, der sich da durchgesetzt hat. Und man sollte sich also zumindestens, wenn man versucht, so eine möglichst große Gruppe anzusprechen, also auch erstmal an Standards halten. Ich bin ja immer skeptisch, wenn einer... Also ohne wirkliche Not... Ich sehe die Not nicht. Warum? Also dieses neue API, wo man es ohne wirkliche Not erstmal daran geht, dann dabei.
Ich sehe schon so ein...
Wir wollen jetzt nicht ins Fachsimpeln geraten.
Nein, wollen wir nicht, will ich auch nicht. Die Not ist sicherlich nicht sehr groß, aber auch nicht so ganz klein. Gerade bei dem RSS merke ich das. Wir haben das jetzt schon ein paar Mal anklingen lassen. Und es ist sicherlich hier in dem Zusammenhang auch durchaus interessant, das mal nochmal anzusprechen, weil es etwas ist, was jeden Neublogger auch zunächst einmal komplett verdurzt. Also ich hatte das auch. Man versucht sich so ein bisschen einzulesen und denkt sich, jetzt kommt dieses so super einfache RSS. Und das lese ich mir jetzt mal durch und dann ist alles prima. Und dann merkt man nämlich irgendwann, dass wenn die Leute RSS sagen, dass sie verschiedene Sachen meinen, das fängt damit an, dass es sehr unterschiedliche Interpretationen gibt, was diese Abkürzung denn tatsächlich bedeutet. Das geht von Really Simple Syndication bis Rich Side Summary. Ja, wo also noch nicht mal gleiche Worte drin sind. Alles ist irgendwie auch richtig.
Richtig super.
Es gibt überhaupt gar keinen Konsens darüber, was denn nun das Richtige ist. Und um es halt noch ein bisschen schlimmer zu machen, gibt es eben auch zwei tatsächlich unterschiedliche, also zwar ähnliche, aber doch technisch betrachtet sehr stark unterschiedliche RSS-Systeme. Und um es noch mal richtig auf die Spitze zu treiben, heißt das eine RSS 1.0 und das andere heißt RSS 2.0. Und jedes hat eine andere Deutung, was das RSS heißt. Und die Versionsnummer lässt auch nicht nacherlegen, dass das 2.0 in irgendeiner Form eine Weiterentwicklung von dem 1.0 ist, sondern nein, es ist noch mal schlimmer. 2.0 ist eine Weiterentwicklung von dem 0.9.1. Und das 1.0 ist eine Weiterentwicklung von dem 0.9.
Ihr besorgt euch ein Programm, was ihr alle lesen kann, und dann scheißt ihr drauf.
Ja gut, aber es ist natürlich in dem Moment, wo man auch selber darüber nachdenkt, das anzubieten, durchaus etwas, was man im Kopf haben muss.
Ja, es hat vor allen Dingen, also, ich mein, man sollte mal sagen, warum das so ist. Also die Entwicklung zu dem RSS 1.0 hin war eben halt eine Entwicklung zu dem, was man semantisches Web nennt, das eben halt eine maschinenlesbare Bedeutung in diesem RSS Feed noch mit reinbringt. Das ist eine Idee, die ich sehr faszinierend halte, wo ich auch noch einige Spielereien im Hinterkopf habe, die ich irgendwann mal verwirklichen werde. Während dieses RSS 0.0.1, respektive dann auch das RSS 2.0, also tatsächlich nur dafür gedacht ist, dass es in diesen Newsreadern gelesen werden kann. Und es ist etwas anderes, zum Beispiel bei diesen Spielereien. Ich habe mir schon mal überlegt, ein automatisches Webblock mit Hilfe von statistischen Filtern zu erstellen. Das heißt, ich lese diese RSS Feeds durch, also respektive ein Programm liest die durch. Dann wichte ich erst mal guter Eintrag, schlechter Eintrag, guter Eintrag, schlechter Eintrag, bis mein Programm das gelernt hat, was ein guter Eintrag ist.
So mit so einem Spamfilter.
So ein Balesfilter dann dabei. Oder man kann andere Sachen, man kann auch ein neuronales Netzwerk draufsetzen oder wie auch immer. Es gibt ja solche Geschichten. Ja, das wusste ich eben. Noch vor dem Zähneputzen. Und ich würde mich wirklich mal interessieren, wie weit sich dann zumindest im Endeffekt die Nachrichtenauswahl von der Nachrichtenauswahl unterscheidet, die ich per Hand getroffen habe und was dann dabei rausgekommen ist. Also ist natürlich erst mal eine gewisse Spielerei, wenn man sieht, wo diese Richtung hingeht. Es ist eine Version, die Alan Kay, also einer der Computer Visionäre, Visionäre aus den 70er, 80er Jahren schon hatte, die auch von Apple mal ziemlich gepusht worden ist. Zum Beispiel, dass man sozusagen die persönliche Tageszeitung bekommt nach seinen Vorlieben, die man sich nach seinen Vorlieben ausgewählt hat und so, wo dann also auch sozusagen das Programm oder der Computer lernt, was ich gerne lese und dem zufolge in der ganzen Welt die Nachrichten zusammensucht und dann das Ganze eben auf dem Monitor darstellt. Also Alan Kay hatte sich dann auch noch einen Computer so in der Form praktisch wie so ein Tablett vorgestellt. Also heute mit dem Tablett Computer kommt man schon fast dabei hin. Das nannte er Dynabook damals und wo man dann also mit einem Stift auch, also der Newton von Apple spielt da auch wieder so ein bisschen mit rein und auch die heutigen Stiftcomputer, tatsächlich mit einem Stift dann sich sozusagen das auch raussuchen kann und diese Nachrichten lesen kann und so. Und das hat er in den 70er, 80er Jahren gemacht. Also es war eine Vision, die damals schon da war. Grundartig. Wo man jetzt eigentlich so hinkommt, dass man sie damit verwirklichen könnte. Und daraus gesehen ist natürlich RSS 2.0 eindeutig ein Rückschritt, weil er nämlich also diese Vision, die man da hatte, dass man damit tatsächlich verwirklichen kann, in RSS 1.0 zwar geht, was sich dann auch RDF Site Syndication nennt. Also RDF ist ein Standard des W3C, also des Standardisierungskomitees für das Internet und heißt also Resource Description Framework. Also etwas, was beschreibt, ich hatte es als Maschinenleser beschreibt, wie man seine Daten, also auch die Meta-Information über die Daten hinterlegt, also wer Autor ist und so weiter und so fort. Und deswegen der Streit eben halt auch. Und ich weiß jetzt eben nicht, ob das Atom RPI dann tatsächlich in die Richtung Resource Description Framework, also wieder semantisches Web geht oder ob es wieder irgendwie eine eigene Suppe kocht. Und deswegen bin ich da momentan noch skeptisch. Aber das werden wir sehen. Also wenn es eine schöne Sache ist, werde ich es auch bei mir implementieren.
Ganz kurz mal eben durchspülen.
Achtung, Achtung, dies ist keine Durchsage.
Und im Radio?
Genau, hier ist das Chaosradio. Und wir haben noch eine gute Stunde Zeit zu quatschen. Ich hoffe, dass der Dominik jetzt dran ist. Ihr könnt wieder Dominik auch anrufen. 031 77 97 110. Und ich setze natürlich Gottvertrauen in meine Technik. Hallo Dominik. Leg mich einer fett erst dran. Hörst du mich?
Fast geklappt.
Und ich höre dich. Och, ist das herrlich. Dominik?
Ja.
Selber Webblogschreiber?
Mittlerweile ja. Also mein erstes Webblog, das ich gelesen habe, war tatsächlich der Schachwillenreiter. Da bin ich 2002 irgendwo drauf gelandet. Da war ein Link von einem Forum. Und da ging es um einen Artikel, wo irgendein Verein irgendwelche Leute denunziert. Ja, und dann bin ich bei irgendwann Mitte des Jahres bei Tim gelandet. Und von dort aus bei movable-typ und ja mittlerweile ist mein eigenes Webblog.
Und was schreibst du so?
Momentan leider viel zu wenig. Also generell quer durch den Gemüsegarten. Und es soll ein bisschen mehr werden, wenn ich mal wieder ein bisschen mehr Zeit habe dafür.
Du kannst ruhig die URL rüberschießen, damit du mehr Besucher hast.
Genau, dann lohnt es sich auch wieder zu schreiben.
Notiert. Wir wollen ja heute Abend auch so ein bisschen so philosophieren über diese ganze Informationskultur, die sich dadurch ergeben hat. Fühlst du dich dadurch informierter, anders informiert, oder was macht für dich das Wesen dieser Weblog-Information aus, die du jetzt wahrscheinlich auch relativ tüchtig sammelst aus verschiedensten Ecken?
Ja, man hat Informationen sehr schnell auf den Blick. Also ich muss nicht irgendwie mit meinem Browser irgendwie 20.000 Seiten aufmachen, ehe ich irgendwie informiert bin. Und ich hab irgendwie auf dem ersten Blick was wichtig ist. Und ich kann auch schon irgendwie an den Headlines entscheiden, irgendwie was mir wichtig ist und was ich irgendwie lesen möchte, oder was ich nicht lesen möchte.
Das geht gut, ja, mit dem Ding?
Naja, könnte besser gehen, irgendwie unter Linux. Gibt's anscheinend keine wirklich vernünftigen.
Stimmt, komisch ist irgendwie. Und der Unix ist noch nicht so richtig, dass die Killer-Applikationen gekommen sind.
Das liegt vielleicht aber auch daran, weil sich die Leute, die unter Linux arbeiten, das alles immer selber schreiben. Und das muss dann im EMAX sein, also wenn sie ihren Feed nicht im EMAX lesen können, dann...
Wobei für den EMAX gibt's doch bestimmt schon RSS.
Ja, es gibt einen Feed. Der Nemo, der war zu süß. Stimmt, ich erinnere mich. Ja, bitte. Blogger lesen ungern E-Mails. Ich hab nämlich Max heute Morgen eine E-Mail geschickt und immer noch keine Antwort.
Ach du dicke Sei. Da war ich beim Hautarzt gerade, glaube ich. Ich war heute Morgen nicht zu Hause. Ich bin direkt zur Arbeit gefahren. Ganz, ganz, wirklich, ganz, ganz pflichtbewusst. Deswegen hab ich die noch nicht gelesen, wahrscheinlich. Ich könnte natürlich von hier zugreifen, aber ich bin tatsächlich eine faule Sau. Außerdem muss ich mal sagen, wahrscheinlich tragen mich jetzt wieder 1500 Leute in irgendwelche verfluchten, in verfluchten Mailinglisten ein. Aber ich krieg ja pro Tag hier, deswegen lese ich wirklich keine Mails mehr. Ungefähr, lass mich nicht lügen, 250 neue Mails. Davon sind 248 Penis-Vergrößerungs-Mails. Slash. Und dann kommen die ganzen anderen. Also ich hab nur noch Spam hier und zwei davon sind irgendwelche Mails, die ich dann wirklich sauer verdienen muss, die meistens von Fritz kommen und dann zwischendurch mal irgendwie eine andere oder so. Aber wenn ich jedes Mal meinen Penis hätte vergrößern lassen, dann läge der jetzt in, lass mich mir wieder nicht lügen. Also deswegen, das mit den Mails, das stimmt schon. Tut mir leid. Musst du ins Webblog schreiben, da gucke ich öfter mal rein, weil das geht schneller.
Und wenn irgendjemand noch irgendwie anruft und einen vernünftigen Fitri dafür Linux weiß, ich bin ja für jeden Tipp dankbar.
Tschüss Dominik.
Also ich will diese These nochmal aufgreifen, da ist ein Fünchen Wahrheit dran. Ich hab bestimmte Sachen tatsächlich bislang über Mail gelesen, wo ich das hab sein lassen. Also Mailinglisten, die halt im Prinzip diesen Newscharakter haben. Da gibt es auch einige, da tue ich das immer noch so. Aber sagen wir mal so was wie den Heise-News-Ticker habe ich lange Zeit per Mail empfangen, über einen Dienst vom Freund, der das gemacht hat, der es sozusagen aus dem Web rausschält. Und mittlerweile kann man halt den Heise-Ticker auch per RSS lesen, wobei man sagen muss Heise, Heise, Heise, also euer RSS-Feed ist wirklich unter aller Sau. Der bietet wirklich nur das Mindeste, ist nicht konfigurierbar, wie viele Artikel man bekommt und hat auch nicht den vollen Content da drin. Das kann man vielleicht noch verstehen bei so kommerziellen Feeds, die dann irgendwie auch ihre Bewertung ihres Erfolges an ihrer Webserver-Statistik ablesen wollen. Aber so richtig toll ist das nicht. Es hat sich allerdings auch mittlerweile, also sogar der Spiegel hat sich mittlerweile gebückt und irgendwie offiziell einen RSS-Feed angeboten, der auch die gleichen Nachteile hat. Und es zeigt sich aber auch, dass ein RSS-Feed sehr wichtig ist mittlerweile für den Newside, um auch Akzeptanz zu finden.
Ja, aber ich möchte auch nochmal an dieser These anknüpfen, ohne direkt auch wieder auf RSS zu kommen. Ich hatte das Thema gerade auch in den letzten Tagen bei mir im Weblog. Ich bekomme tatsächlich auch sehr viele Mails. Ich bekomme mehr Mails, als ich abarbeiten kann. Also schon noch die, selbst die, die noch durch meinen Spamfilter rutschen. Weil die Penisvergrößerung kriege ich schon gar nicht mehr. Das verpasst du was. Es sind vielfach einfach auch Anfragen, die besser beantwortet werden, wenn sie in meinen Kommentaren auftauchen würden. Gerade auch weil ich nun einen Artikel bei mir auch zu RSS habe, bekomme ich zum Beispiel sehr viele Anfragen zu RSS. Wenn solche Fragen sind, schreibt die in meine Kommentare. Also alle Artikel auch bei mir, die haben diese Kommentarfunktion freigeschaltet, schreibt die in diese Kommentare. Diese Fragen interessieren bestimmt auch andere. Und ich beantworte irgendwann nicht mehr, wenn ich zum fünften Mal die gleiche Frage beantworten muss, weil das wird dann irgendwie langweilig und finde ich auch irgendwie dann nicht mehr so prickelnd dabei. Also solche Sachen, also ich helfe gerne und ich hätte sowas aber wirklich dann gerne in diesen Kommentaren, weil dann ist auch wieder das Webblog so etwas erfüllt, was andere immer da auch reininterpretieren, obwohl ich da selber ein bisschen skeptisch bin, dass es auch so etwas wie eine Wissensdatenbank ist. Wenn solche Fragen auch da sind, solche Fragen beantwortet sind, dann sind die auch für alle anderen lesbar, dann bieten sie auch so etwas wie eine Art FAQ oder so, wo man dann wirklich sagen kann, okay, hier meine Fragen zu RSS, sind alle in diesem Artikel zu RSS unten drunter aufgelistet, da kann ich nachgucken, was steht denn da, hat vielleicht schon mal jemand dieses gehabt. Und wenn es dann da nicht drin steht, dann stellt die Frage da. Dann ist es für die Nächsten wieder okay, dann kann man das wieder machen und es stimmt schon. Manchmal entschuldige ich mich in meinem Webblog auch dafür, dass ich seit drei Tagen durch meine E-Mail-Ackere und immer noch nicht fertig bin, dass die Leute bitte mit ihrer Antwort nicht sauer sein sollen, wenn die Antwort nicht so schnell kommt. Und manchmal kommt sie auch einfach gar nicht, weil ich irgendwann mal sage, jetzt hast du 14 Tage überlegt, wie du diese E-Mail beantwortest, jetzt ist sie auch nicht mehr aktuell. Jetzt schiebst du sie sofort weg dann dabei. Es tut mir dann immer irgendwie ein bisschen leid, aber irgendwo ist auch immer die Kapazität begrenzt.
Aber ich habe ähnliche Erfahrungen gemacht. So Wissenstatenbank, ich benutze es selber als Wissenstatenbank, als meine eigene. Das heißt in dem Moment, wo ich eine konkrete Problemlösung habe oder zumindest einen Ansatz zu einer Problemlösung. Ich habe das mal zu so einem iChat Problem mit den Firewalls, mit dem NAT irgendwie gemacht. Und interessanterweise kamen sehr viele Leute auch noch Wochen später mit Kommentaren und Checkbacks auf diesen Artikel, weil das bei Google relativ hoch drin war, wenn man die iChat Troubleshooting eingab, dann war das irgendwie der erste oder zweite Link. Für eine Weile, ich weiß nicht, ob das immer noch so ist. Und auch selber, ich auch selber habe, häufig wenn ich ein konkretes Problem hatte, wenn ich irgendwelche Fehlermeldungen oder so hatte, wo ich mir dachte, hm, einfach mal die Fehlermeldungen in Google reinpasten, Return funktioniert immer super. Also falls ihr immer schon immer mal einen Fehler hatte, den ihr nicht versteht, einfach mal die Fehlermeldungen so direkt in Google reinwerfen, das ist unglaublich, was man da für Antworten bekommt. Und in letzter Zeit ist es einfach sehr häufig ein Webblog, was die Antwort liefert. Das ist schon sehr auffällig.
Ähm, ich würde gerne noch was loswerden, weil die Blogosphere schläft ja nie. Ihr könnt übrigens auch anrufen, ihr müsst nicht nur bloggen, weil ich merke ja, dass hier ganz viele mitschreiben. 0331 77 97 110 ist die Nummer. Wir werden gleich auch mal eine schöne Frage stellen, die ihr wunderbar provoziert oder auch nicht, das hängt ja von euch ab. Aber bei uns im Board, auf fritz.de slash, oh man, Boards, Chat, also einfach von vorne durchklicken. Mein Gott, ich vergesse es jedes Mal. Einfach auf Boards und auf Fritz-Board klicken. Da hat der Thomas einen Eintrag gemacht, und zwar Blogosphere über Sendung Blogosphäre, also das, was gebloggt wird über uns, was im Grunde von Anfang der Sendung an ein Mitschnitt ist über das, was wir erzählt haben, und zwar handschriftlich verfasst, wobei ich grundsätzlich sagen muss, wir sind nicht der SWR, sondern vom RBB und Fritz. Also das könnt ihr vielleicht mal ändern, weil ich liess da die ganze Zeit SWR. Und da stehen auch alle Empfehlungen, die wir schon mal gegeben haben am heutigen Abend. Insofern gibt's da eine schöne Mitschrift, wenn man so möchte. Sehr schön. Und das wollte ich endlich mal loswerden. Eine gute Adresse, bei der man auch vorbeischauen kann, ist noch ein bisschen aus einer Standardadresse, kann man ruhig mal sagen, ist bloghouse.de mit G geschrieben. Also das ist ja der Wortwitz, nicht wahr? Bloghouse mit G.
Aber Haus auf Deutsch. Haus auf Deutsch oder auf Englisch?
Auf Deutsch. Also zu schwierig, wollen wir sie auch nicht machen. Auf Türkisch. Und dann anders geschrieben. Und da findet ihr auch ganz, ganz viele Links zum Anfang. Also wenn ihr irgendwelche Programme braucht oder wenn ihr wissen wollt, was kann ich für Software benutzen, die haben sich immer die Arbeit gemacht. Die reden nämlich nur übers Bloggen. Da kann man so lesen, was so für die Anfänger am besten ist. Ansonsten fände ich für die letzte Stunde mal ganz toll, weil wir jetzt ja auch darüber reden so viel übers Bloggen und wir machen es auch sehr gerne, aber ist der Hype nicht schon wieder vorbei? Das ist eine Frage, die ich habe. Also ist es nicht schon wieder an Deutschland vorübergegangen? Ist Bloggen nicht tot? Und da möchte ich auch mit euch sprechen in Berlin und Brandenburg. 0371 77 97 110. Und wenn ihr aus ganz Deutschland anruft, könnt ihr das auch gerne unter dieser Nummer tun. Die ist nicht irgendwie beschränkt oder so. Ist Bloggen in Wirklichkeit schon wieder tot? Haben die Amis vielleicht die Lust dran verloren? Es gibt jetzt noch so zwei, drei. Und wird es in Deutschland nie groß werden? Weil es ja schon eine relativ selektierte Community ist.
Also das sind zwei Fragen. Also die Frage ist da halb vorbei. Würde ich ziemlich eindeutig mit Nein beantworten, weil also gerade in der letzten Zeit ja auch neue Anbieter, mehr oder weniger wie Pilze, aus dem Boden schießen. Mit Blogger.de und Blog.de mit 2G hinten. Ich glaube, beide Anbieter bieten auch die Möglichkeit, kostenlos Webblogs zu hosten. 20.6 ist vorhin schon mal gefallen. Ist auch irgendwie einer, der das natürlich aus kommerziellen Interessen macht. Aber das muss ja im Prinzip erstmal nichts Schlechtes sein.
AOL nicht zu vergessen?
Ich weiß, gibt es in AOL.de schon einen Dienst? Ich glaube nicht. Soweit wie ich weiß, erst mal nur in den USA. Aber die zweite Frage weiß ich nicht zu beantworten, ob also das in Deutschland so populär wird, wie es in einigen anderen Ländern ist. Wir hatten ja vorhin schon mal Persien, Polen, aber auch die USA. Ich habe da irgendwie ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass es in Deutschland eine gewisse Scheu gibt zu publizieren. Ich weiß aber auch nicht, was das da so genau ist.
Sag mal, wusstest du, dass mit SWR der Schockwellenreiter selbst gemeint ist?
Ja, das kommt manchmal vor dann dabei. Es gibt Leute, die kürzen ihn so ab.
Ja, habe ich dir gerade gelesen. Schön, dass du nichts gesagt hast, Jörg. Finde ich toll. Mich wieder voll ins Messer reinlassen. Die Community lacht über mich. Gut, das wollte ich nur kurz erwähnen. Oder VGK ist wahrscheinlich meine. Die langen müssen immer lagen.
Da haben wir zumindest mal neue Namen für uns.
Ja, jetzt hast du mich aber irgendwie rausgebracht. Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wo ich stecken geblieben war.
Ich musste gerade eben laut schreien, deswegen weiß ich es jetzt auch nicht mehr.
Jetzt musst du die Überleitung machen.
Warte, ich helfe Jörg auf die Sprünge. Jörg, worüber hast du denn gerade gesprochen?
Ich glaube, ich war stehen geblieben bei der Frage, ob es jemals so viele Blogger in Deutschland geben wird.
Ja, und ob die Deutschen eigentlich nicht gerne schreiben. Also, dass sie sich selbst rausgehen.
Ja, es hat vielleicht so irgendwie etwas mit dem, was Lenin schon mal festgestellt hat. Wenn die Deutschen eine Revolution machen, brauchen sie erst eine Fahrkarte. Und solange niemand Bloggen offiziell für den Hype erklärt hat, macht den auch keiner als Hype oder so. Aber vielleicht ist es auch etwas Gutes daran. Es hat dadurch tatsächlich so etwas Graswurzelartiges. Ich muss ihn nicht als Hype haben, aber ich bin auch nicht dagegen, wenn es ein Hype sein wird. Im Gegensatz, manchmal hört man so ein bisschen Abfälligkeiten, also auch gerade über 26 Blogger oder so. Also ich denke, jeder, der irgendwie so etwas macht, ob es dieses 26 ist oder ob es diese Internet-Tagebücher sind oder so, also jeder, der irgendwie so etwas macht, bereichert das Ganze. Also ob das einem jetzt persönlich gefällt oder persönlich nicht gefällt, man weiß ja selber auch meinen Standpunkt zu Tagebüchern oder Ähnlichem dann dabei. Aber man sollte es machen und es bereichert das Ganze dann dabei. Es ist eine Form der Gegenöffentlichkeit und es ist eine gewisse Form der Graswurzelgeschichte. Es ist vorbei an all diesen, was man darf und was man nicht darf, was man muss und wo man dann Rücksicht nehmen muss. Man ist selber nur dafür verantwortlich, man macht das in seiner Verantwortung und man sollte sich auch von niemanden reinreden lassen. Also weil wir das vorhin ja schon mal zum Beispiel auch hatten mit dem Design. Also ich weiß selber, dass das Design des Schockwellenreins nicht unbedingt das gelbe vom Ei ist. Aber ich werde allen Anfechtungen zum Trotz, ich werde es schlicht und einfach beibehalten, weil es mir gefällt und das ist mein Ding dann dabei und das ist mein Blog. Und da kommt rein, was mir gefällt und es sieht so aus, wie es mir gefällt. Und das ist einfach, ich glaube, das ist auch das, was das ausmacht, diese Persönlichkeit, die dahintersteht, so eine gewisse Personality, die dann dabei ist. Man hat eben nicht irgendwie eine doch relativ anonyme Redaktion oder so etwas, sondern man hat eben halt, sei es jetzt bei Scripting News der Weiner oder sei es beim Schockwellenreiter eben halt auch Jörg Kantel. Und das ist die Person, die dahintersteht. Und jeder, der so etwas aufmacht, der steht mit seiner Person dahinter. Und das ist sein Ding.
Da sag ich doch nur, ausdrucken.
Den wir ruhig aufklären können, also das steht ja gerne bei dir auf der Seite, Jörg, wenn es dann etwas längere Seiten sind, wo man am Monitor müde wird, dann sagst du immer ausdruckendes Pflicht.
Ausdrucken, Ausrufezeichen und besonders wichtige schreibe ich dann auch noch hinter Ausdrucken, Ausrufezeichen, Lesen, Ausrufezeichen, weil das ist eher, ich arbeite ja selber im Wissenschaftsbetrieb und da gibt es dann auch immer diesen Satz, nicht kopieren, sondern kapieren. Weil der Ausstoß aus dem Fotokopierer, der bringt so viele Seiten raus, die mit Sicherheit alle nicht gelesen werden. Und das reicht eben auch oftmals auch nicht. Manchmal reicht das aber auch.
Ich fand es ganz schön, wenn vielleicht ein paar, die Webblogs genießen und sich damit auch beschäftigen, hier anrufen könnten unter 033 171 97 110. Und einfach mal für all diejenigen, die sich jetzt denken, ja gut, das ist halt eine Informationsquelle wie jeder andere. Ich lese halt als spiegel.de oder golem oder heise oder was auch immer. Und mal so eine exemplarische Geschichte erzählen. Weil den meisten von uns wird schon mal was untergekommen sein, wo ihr sagt, also bin ich da und da vorbeigesurft und habe die Geschichte gelesen. Die habe ich wirklich erst vier Wochen später woanders gesehen. Oder das war was, das hat mich nur dargelesen. Das hat mich fasziniert und da habe ich auch einen Link drauf gesetzt. Wenn ihr sowas habt, dann ruft mal an bei uns und erzählt davon, weil wir wollen ja auch ein bisschen für dieses Medium Webblogs faszinieren heute Abend und dazu brauchen wir eure Geschichten.
Damit es eben doch ein Hype wird.
Eben, damit es ein Hype wird, was auch sonst. Also wenn jetzt hier 4-5 Leute das erzählen, dann wird es garantiert ein Hype.
Mir fallen da gleich Geschichten zu ein und zwar Geschichten, über die ich selber nicht gebloggt habe. Ich setze nicht alles irgendwie in meinen Webblog, sondern eben nur so ausgewähltes und eben auch Sachen, die ich irgendwie voll verstehe. Aber es gibt so Sachen, wo ich irgendwie doch eine große Distanz habe, die aber trotzdem sehr interessant sind und mindestens einem ein Gefühl geben, auch wenn man es nicht danach unbedingt bewerten kann. Ein gutes Beispiel ist dieser Irak-Blogger, der während des Krieges oder doch noch als der Krieg angefangen hat, aber schon im Vorfeld gebloggt hat, der einen Internetzugang hatte in Bagdad. Die Webseite ist bekannt unter dem Namen WhereIsRaid, R-A-I-D. Wenn man danach sucht, findet man die URL sofort. Der ist natürlich zwangsläufig schnell bekannt geworden in der Blogosphere, weil das natürlich eine ganz besondere Geschichte war. Er hat weitgehend anonym aus Bagdad berichtet und eben täglich so seine Impression von dem, was um ihn herum passiert, berichtet dann eben auch noch während des Krieges, bis es dann irgendwann stumm wurde um ihn und keiner so richtig wusste, ob ihn die Bombe jetzt getroffen hat, hatte sie nicht. Mittlerweile schreibt er, glaube ich, für die Times und ist natürlich zu einiger Berühmtheit gelangt dadurch, ist aber noch sehr zurückhaltend und gibt auch so seine Identität öffentlich nicht preis, was sicherlich eine gute Idee ist. Über dieses Webblog bin ich dann auch über an andere Irak bezogene Webblogs gekommen, vor allem auch auf das von amerikanischen Soldaten, die doch teilweise sehr kritisch aus ihrer Position heraus berichtet haben, was sicherlich auch ein zweischleidiges Schwert ist, da sie ja da auch unter ständiger Beobachtung stehen. Da will ich jetzt gar nicht auf so eine besondere Geschichte raus, wollte das einfach nur mal anregen. Das ist schon eine Art Nachricht, die es so eigentlich gar nicht gibt, weil sie gar nicht für die normalen Nachrichtenkanäle als Nachricht verwertbar ist. Das sind einfach die Nachrichten zwischen den Zeilen, das ist einfach das Gefühl, was man rausliest, womit man eben einen Eindruck bekommt für etwas. Ähnlich aufschlussreich fand ich dann auch Webblog-artige Webseiten, die während des Krieges ihr Ohr an den russischen Geheimdiensten dran hatten und so das, was irgendwie dort von der russischen Seite her abgehört wurden, dann die ganzen militärischen Auswertungen berichtet haben, wo man eben auch die großen Gegensätze gesehen hat zwischen dem, was die einen sagen, und dem, was die offizielle Darstellung ist. Unabhängig davon, was jetzt irgendwie richtiger ist, aber es klaffte einfach enorm, enorm auseinander. Und auch das war etwas, was ich so vorher noch nicht gehabt habe im Netz.
Das ist das, wo wir vorhin schon mal waren, das war im Grunde auch das, was ich meinte, wo es darum geht, wo du gesagt hast, wenn man viele, viele Leser hat, Jörg, dann muss man halt gucken, dass man da journalistischer vorgeht. Aber grundsätzlich ist man nicht dran gebunden, ein Thema erst dann bringen zu können, wenn es so diesem klassischen Aufhänger-Journalismus genüge tut. Also Journalisten machen Sachen auch erst dann, wenn irgendwie der Chef sagt, hat das irgendeinen Aufhänger, gibt es da ein Treffen, haben wir da schon mal welche von auf der Straße lesen, gibt es da eine Demo oder so. Und wenn das nicht ist, dann passiert das auch nicht.
Das ist generell natürlich freier, weil das hängt aber auch wieder damit zusammen, dass man ja eben sein Werbys mal im Tagesspiegel gestanden hat, das ein bisschen aufgeregt hat. Aber jeder sein eigener Chefredakteur dann tatsächlich ist. Also wie Don't Need No Stinky Chefredakteur. Und man kann halt tatsächlich so schreiben, wie man selber denkt, dass es geschrieben werden muss. Aber man muss sich natürlich auch dann immer wieder fragen, ob man sich nicht auch selber seinen eigenen Aufhänger sucht dann dabei. Ich glaube, das ist eher eine Geschichte, die dann durchhängt, dass es die Masse macht, weil nämlich eben jeder dann einen anderen Aufhänger hat. Dann sind diese Sachen einfach wieder weg. Man sollte nicht nur einen Webblog zur Information lesen, dann auch mit anderen dabei.
Ich finde es nur schön, für mich ist es zum Beispiel manchmal ganz hilfreich, dass bestimmte Sachen, die ich bei Fritz so nicht erzählen könnte, weil sie eben nicht so ein Paket sind, was man so abliefern kann, wie es halt üblicherweise konsumiert wird, sondern dass man so etwas abliefert in seinem Webblog wie die Hintergrundinformation. Das sind dann nicht mehr als Hintergrundinformation. Das ist so etwas wie so ein Rechercheskript, wo man gesagt hat, ich bin da und da vorbeigeschöpft, das und das gefunden, das und das. Interessanter Zusammenhang, Punkt. Und das könnte man aber so nicht verkaufen, da könnte auch keiner einen Artikel in der Zeitung drüber schreiben, weil es eben nicht genug ist.
Ja, du hast doch irgendwie, ich hörte doch mal so eine Serie, wo du diese Geschichte nachgegraben hast. Das ist lange her, Junge.
Bürgerkonvent war das.
Genau, Bürgerkonvent. Da hat es ja doch, glaub ich, auch einige Aufmerksamkeit.
Das war insofern lustig, als ich damals dieser Bürgerkonvent, ich war relativ betrunken an einem Samstagabend und meine Freundin und ich hatten nichts zu tun und waren auch zu betrunken zum Sex. Das war wahrscheinlich der Hauptgrund. Jedenfalls haben wir uns dann entschlossen, Werbung zu gucken. Dann kam diese Werbung und die lief an dem Samstag das erste Mal. Dann habe ich mich betrunken dazu entschlossen, mal nachzugucken, was so die Hintergründe sind. Dadurch war ich der Erste, der bei Google da drin stand. Daraufhin kamen dann wirklich alle. Also so Monitor des Fernsehmagazins und so. Alle möglichen Leute haben dann zuerst mal einen Link gefunden und gefragt, woher ich dann diese Informationen hätte. Obwohl ich halt gerade erst mit Bloggen auch angefangen hatte. Da kommen ja auch nicht viele Leute zu mir. Das war so High Times. Das war unglaublich. Und das passiert einem halt, wenn man bloggt. Deswegen macht das manchmal ganz, ganz viel Spaß.
Ja, das ist auch was, wo die Frage, wie Google auf Blogger wirkt oder wie Blogger via Google auf andere wirken. Also ich hab mittlerweile auch den Eindruck, dass eine sehr große Anzahl von Journalisten sich tatsächlich ihre Informationen via Google besorgt. Und da Weblogs häufig auch relativ hoch gerenkt sind bei bestimmten Anfragen, sie dann tatsächlich auch wiederum als Informationsquelle für Journalisten dienen. Ich kommentiere das dann halt manchmal schon so. Gestern stand das im Schockwellenreiter. Heute steht es bei Heise. Und das ist halt auch immer die Frage, wo ich mir die Frage stelle, wo dieses Multiplikative herkommt. Also das war auch diese Geschichte, wie ich damals vom Surkamp Verlag abgemahnt worden war. Das war an einem Freitagnachmittag. Ich habe das Freitagabend in meinen Webblog gestellt und schon am Wochenende klingelte ununterbrochen bei mir das Telefon, weil Journalisten aus der ganzen Republik bei mir angerufen hatten und wissen wollten, was da los ist. Das ging relativ schnell. Kannst du nochmal erklären, worum es ging dabei? Ich hatte einen Link in meinen Webblog gesetzt auf die damals im Internet kursierende Version von Tod eines Kritikers von Martin Walzer. Der Surkamp Verlag hat mich dann abgemahnt und auf die Entfernung dieses Links bestanden. Der Link war zum Zeitpunkt der Abmahnung schon tot. Aber gut, dann gab es ein bisschen Hin und Her. Und Surkamp und ich haben uns geeinigt. Ich musste nichts bezahlen, um das mal sozusagen.
Solche Geschichten erlebt man natürlich, wenn man viele Leser hat, weil die dann eher Angst bekommen, dass es zu große Resonanz führen könnte. Wenn man noch so ganz klein ist, hat man manchmal Glück und schlüpft einfach so durchs Netz. Sebastian ist am Telefon aus Berlin. Hallo Sebastian. Du bist auch Webblogger.
Und zwar wollte ich eigentlich einen Programm vorschlagen. Vielleicht habt ihr schon darüber gesprochen. Und zwar nennt sich das Clip-Polio. Kennt ihr das vielleicht?
Ich kenne es, ja. Das ist auch so etwas Ähnliches, wo man diese Nachrichten lesen kann. Aber es hat zwei große Nachteile. Einmal entspricht es keinem einzigen Standard. Und der andere ist, es funktioniert nicht auf dem Macintosh.
Ich nutze das auf meinem PC ganz normal. Und das ist ganz nett, weil da laufen die Nachrichten so durch, wie so ein Nachrichtenticker.
Ich weiß, ja. Ich habe den jetzt mal angeguckt. Aber wie gesagt, das läuft nicht auf dem Macintosh, unter Linux schon mal gar nicht. Es ist eine reine Microsoft-eigene Geschichte, die funktioniert nur da.
Na gut, aber für so kleinere Sachen wie Heise oder so ein N24 oder Tagesschau reicht es völlig aus.
Das ist ja auch die eher uninteressanten Quellen.
Ja, sowas, was man allgemein nebenbei mal mit lesen kann.
Ich weiß auch jetzt gar nicht, wie viele da auf diesen Zug aufgesprungen sind. Vor einem halben Jahr war das mal ziemlich populär. Ich hatte aber noch den Eindruck, dass es dann sehr schnell wieder abflachte, das Interesse daran. Und ich weiß jetzt gar nicht, wer dies überhaupt noch anbietet, dieses Clipfolio-Format, das kann ich jetzt gar nicht sagen.
Na, CSS-Technik ist dabei, Tagesschau, Dr. Web. Was gibt es denn noch? Dann haben wir ja noch Golem gibt es noch, also eher die kleineren Sachen.
Ja, eher die größeren Sachen.
Das sind eher die größeren, würde ich sagen. Also Heise oder Golem oder auch Dr. Web sind ja nun sehr populäre Seiten im Web. Aber es sind... Ja, ne. Also wie gesagt, es gibt es, es entspricht keinem Standard. Es läuft nur unter Windows und ich glaube nicht, dass es also ein zukunftsfähiges Format ist.
Kann ich vielleicht noch was anderes sagen? Morgen tagsüber um 12 Uhr ist die Demo der Studenten von Berlin. Und da möchte ich doch alle Studenten nochmal aufrufen, dahin zu kommen.
Und wo?
Am Potsdamer Platz.
Vom Potsdamer Platz zum Roten Rathaus, wenn ich das richtig weiß. Ja, ich rufe...
Ich glaub, die Demo-Termine stehen auch bei uns im Board nochmal. Also wenn ihr Fritz.de aufs Board...
Ansonsten stehen sie mit Sicherheit auch im Schockwellenreiter. Wenn die Telekom mich heute nochmal wieder ranlässt, momentan ist es weg. Und im Webblog meines Hundes. Also da werden momentan die ganzen Demo-Termine aufgeführt. Also cbu.server-wg.de, um das auch nochmal loszuwerden. Also auch da nochmal alle hinsurfen, mein Hund freut sich.
Wenn das Tier wieder aktueller ist als der Mensch, dann ist alles in Ordnung. Wenn du Webblogger bist, was machst du so und worüber schreibst du? Und ich möchte gerne mal endlich meine Geschichte hören. Irgendwo eine, die du irgendwo gefunden hast, wo du sagst, das hat mich damals fasziniert und das gab es nirgendwo anders.
Also ich schreib in meinem Webblog hauptsächlich, weil ich relativ viel Sport mache über meine ganzen Sporterlebnisse, was ich so bei irgendwelchen Wettkämpfen erlebt habe.
Ich dachte du sagst jetzt Sportverletzungen.
Nee, nee, also irgendwie, wenn es ganz toll gelaufen ist oder so, ist in der Richtung. Also auch das ist meine Kumpel, ist einfach nur Lesen. Also gar nicht so für die große weite Welt, sondern eher so für den kleinen Bekanntenkreis. Also mein Cousin ist in Amerika und der liest dann immer verfleißig meinen Webblog. Und so wird halt einfach untereinander das bisschen ausgetauscht.
Aber auch du kannst die URL ruhig rüber schießen, damit du ein paar Laser bekommst.
Und irgendwas, was dich mal fasziniert hat, was du gelesen hast oder gefunden hast, was wirklich mal Inhalt war, Content?
Ach, eigentlich nichts Großes, eher so die, sagen wir mal, persönlichen Sachen. Ich hab viel von Fritz übernommen, z.B. hab ich einen Holzhuhn gewonnen. Und das Holzhuhn hab ich dann gleich in meinen Webblog eingebaut. Und daraufhin haben einige meiner Freunde mich groß als Glückspilz gefeiert.
Ist doch wenigstens ein nettes Erlebnis. Ja, sowas suchen wir noch. Also ruft mal an, Leute. 033 177 97 110. Das ist wirklich diese, die Blogger sind Schreib unfaul und also wirklich Redefaul hoch 10. Wahrscheinlich lese ich mir heute Nacht dann noch die Finger wund, in dem ich überall vorbeisurfen stehe. Also was die alles erzählt haben.
Weißt du, Geier, was jetzt schon alles in der Logosphäre über diese Sendung geschrieben wird und schon wieder kommentiert ist, wie viele Trackbacks durch die Gegend fliegen.
Ja bitte, ich dann erklär's jetzt aber auch mal. Sebastian, vielen Dank für den Anruf. Also Trackbacks, Tim, damit du endlich urst.
Ja, ja.
Gerade wo wir jetzt sozusagen auch nochmal Google angesprochen haben und die Sache mit den Links. Also jeder weiß ja, dass Googles Erfolg primär darauf basiert, dass er, dass Google ein anderes Bewertungsschema aufgerufen hat, als das andere Suchmaschinen vorher getan haben. Nur Worte finden allein hat nicht gereicht, sondern die Bewertung der Seiten, die eben bestimmte Suchworte enthalten, stieg mit der Zahl der Links von anderen Seiten da drauf. Das ist eigentlich ein sehr erfolgreiches Modell und auch wenn es da in Teilen immer wieder Probleme mit gibt, auch jetzt Spammer versuchen ja sozusagen auch mit solchen Link-Farms dort aufzusteigen. Trotz alledem ist das ein gutes Modell und da Webblogging per se sehr linkreich ist, also fast jeder Eintrag ist ein Link auf eine andere Seite, die dann auch aktuell ist, da ist, also es sind auch frische Links im Sinne von kürzlich erst erstellt und sie funktionieren auch und dort geht es dann wieder weiter. Das ist also eigentlich das ideale Futter und auch das war, als Google blogger.com gekauft hat. Natürlich eine der Mutmaßungen, ob jetzt generell Webblogs auch eine große Rolle spielen in der zukünftigen Strategie von Google. Wie dem auch sei.
Hast du das Wort Trackbacks jetzt schon mal wieder benutzt?
Das geht jetzt gleich los. Diese Vernetzung der Blogosphäre ist ein einerseits ein Phänomen, auf der anderen Seite bringt es auch neue Innovationen und dieses Trackback ist eine der Innovationen, die mich am meisten begeistert hat, als ich darauf gestoßen bin. Wurde eben von diesem Moveable Type Personal Publishing System einst erfunden, mittlerweile auch von anderen Systemen übernommen. Mittlerweile auch von Herrn Weiner, unserem texanischen Freund. Ist eine ganz einfache Sache. Ich lese in deinem Webblog über Eintrag X so und ich finde das toll und schreibe jetzt selber einen Eintrag in meinem Webblog und beziehe mich sozusagen auf deinen Webblog, auf diesen Eintrag. Dann füge ich meinem Eintrag einen Link darauf hinzu und entweder automatisch oder von mir manuell angestoßen veranlasst mein Webblog System, dass anderen Webblog System, was halt gelingt wurde, ein so genannter Trackback oder ein Trackback-Ping geschickt wird. Im Prinzip ist es einfach ein kleines Datenpaket, was da hinfliegt und sagt Hallo, ich habe auf deinem Server, in deinem Webblog folgenden Eintrag gelingt. Und üblicherweise wird diese Information dort aufgenommen und erscheint wie ein Kommentar in diesem Webblog. Und ohne, dass man sozusagen in dem anderen Webblog einen Inhalt hinterlässt, ist aber diese Vernetzungsinformation da. Das hat für denjenigen, der gelingt wurde, auch den Vorteil, dass üblicherweise bei ihm gleich ein E-Mail eintritt, wo drin steht, hier hat jemand auf dich gelingt. Und auch andere können da darüber sozusagen Reaktionen nachvollziehen. Eins der Webblogs, die ich lese, wo sehr kräftig Nutzen gemacht wird von dem Trackback ist Surfing Safari, ein Webblog, was sich um die Programmierung von dem Safari-Webbrowser auf dem Macintosh dreht, das einer der Entwickler schreibt. Und er hat häufig so Aufrufe zu Kommentaren zu bestimmten Eigenschaften seines Programms oder seines Verhaltens. Primär geht es dann immer um das Rendering des HTML oder des CSS oder was man so in der Zukunft mal machen sollte. Und anfangs hat er das über Kommentare gemacht, dann wurde ihm das irgendwann zu viel mit den Kommentaren, weil auch eben zu viele neue Fragen da sind und zu viel, wie soll ich sagen, ich weiß nicht, ob du die Erfahrung auch gemacht hast, dass die Kommentare so eine gewisse Qualitätsarmut aufweisen, die dann eben einen auch an der Stelle überschütten. Also von Email mal ganz abgesehen. Und er hat dann irgendwie, es hat dazu übergegangen, für bestimmte Fragen komplett auf Kommentare zu verzichten und zu sagen, ich antworte hier nur auf Trackbacks. Ich erwarte sozusagen eine Diskussion in der Blogosphäre. Und das wurde dann auch sehr kräftig aufgegriffen. Es steht natürlich nur den Leuten offen, die auch selber so ein trackbackfähiges Weblog haben. Aber das waren immer noch genug, sodass eben auf einen Eintrag von ihm 20, 30 Trackbacks kamen, die man eben hinterherklicken konnte. Und dadurch hatten diese Kommentare eine andere Qualität, weil man natürlich selber einen Eintrag in seiner eigenen Webseite machen muss, um darauf zu antworten. Und der Mehrwert der Beiträge einfach größer war. Viele haben bei den Kommentaren irgendwie, ja, ich hab hier noch einen Bugreport und haben sich aber was komplett anderes bezogen. Und das macht man halt nicht, wenn man sein eigenes Webblog schreibt. Also das finde ich eine sehr schöne Sache und ist auch sehr dynamisch. Ich sehe so ein bisschen die Geburtsstunde eines noch dynamischeren Webs da drin, wo man also einfach auch die Schreibaktivität live mitbekommen kann und halte das für eine der Killerfunktionen.
Ja, es ist zumindestens etwas, also den Grad der Vernetzung nochmal erhöht und fördert dann dabei. Ich mache das ja erst seit vier Wochen mit diesem Trackback. Ich kann da also über die Erfahrung noch nicht so viel sagen dann dabei. Es ist zurzeit aber leider noch so, dass noch nicht alle Weblog-Software dieses Trackback unterstützt. Das muss man auch sehen. Es ist vor allen Dingen schwierig für Weblog-Systeme, die eben halt keine dynamischen Seiten produzieren, also Trackback zu unterstützen. Sie arbeiten da... Also Radio Userland arbeitet da irgendwie mit so einem Hintertürchen-Trick durch ein irgendwo auf irgendeinem Server liegendes CGI, das dann also beim Renderprozess, wenn die Seiten rausgerendert werden, dann erstmal auch nochmal danach guckt Lichter an Trackback vor. Das heißt also, solange wie nicht neue Seiten geschrieben werden, also neue Weblog-Informationen gepostet werden, weiß das Ding erstmal noch nichts davon dann dabei. Es ist ein schwieriges Ding, aber ich halte es natürlich auch für ein... also für faszinierend. Das ist auch so ein bisschen diesen Peer-to-Peer-Gedanken so ein bisschen fördert. Also ich... und eben halt auch eher einem Weblog, also einem Weblog vielleicht auch angemessener ist, als Kommentare abzugeben dann dabei. Also wenn man das in seinem eigenen Weblog macht und man dann aber trotzdem die Möglichkeit hat, weil er zumindestens ansatzweise dann eben steht, also hier wurde das und das per Trackback geschickt. Also ansatzweise dann die Möglichkeit gibt, also auch durch eine Diskussion, auch wenn sie auf mehrere Webblogs verteilt ist, zu verfolgen auch, weil das war ja bisher oft eine Schwierigkeit. Also was weiß ich, sagen wir jetzt mal, um bei bekannt von mir gelesene Webblogs zu bleiben, also Industrial Technology and Witchcraft schreibt irgendetwas, ich kommentiere das in meinem Blog, Plastic Sinking Org bezieht sich auf einen Kommentar, in seinem Kommentar wiederum, auf den Eintrag von meinem Blog und so weiter. Dass dann Industrial Technology und Witchcraft das eigentlich gar nicht mehr mitkriegt, dass da immer noch eine Diskussion über diesen Eintrag läuft. Und mit diesen Trackbacks wird dann eben halt derjenige informiert. Also hier sieht man, hier läuft noch eine Diskussion über diesen Eintrag dann dabei. Und das macht das dann auch wieder spannend. Und ich bin mal gespannt, was sich daraus entwickelt. Momentan muss, glaube ich, auch noch ein gewisser Standardisierungsprozess stattfinden dabei.
Es ist erstmal so eine Technology Demonstration. Aber es ist interessant. Man muss auch nochmal abwarten, bis die Spammer, also ich sehe da ein großes Potential für Missbrauch durch Spam, weil im Prinzip mir ja jeder ein Check, aber es ist einfach die Wahrheit. Ich meine, wir haben das Problem jetzt auch schon in den Kommentaren, so gerade bei den movable-type-basierten Webblogs. Ich habe so alle zwei Tage habe ich irgendwie wieder so einen Order Viagra online Kommentar drin, voll mit irgendwie tonnenweise Links. Da gibt es halt gerade diese Hoffnung, da über Google höhere Bewertung zu bekommen für die blöden Seiten, wie dem auch immer sei. Das bedarf noch einer, ja, einer Modifizierung.
Maturisierung, mein lieber Schwan.
Ey, das klingt aber wieder geil.
Das klingt so super, dass wir jetzt erstmal Nachrichten machen.
Dann Fritz in Rathenow. Teil 102, 6.
Wir haben es 0 Uhr 31.
Fritz Info.
Ach und das Wetter, herrlich. In der Nacht bewölkt sich es immer mehr. Es regnet ab und zu, die Temperaturen sinken auf 7 bis 4 Grad. Am Tag ist es vormittags noch regnerisch, später dann freundlicher. Bei maximal 9 bis 11 Grad. Jetzt die Meldung mit Bastian Berner.
In der italienischen Botschaft in Bagdad hat sich am Abend eine Explosion ereignet. Nach Augenzeugenberichten wurde das Haus von einer Rakete getroffen. Wie das italienische Fernsehen berichtete, war das Gebäude offenbar leer. Informationen über Verletzte oder Tote gibt es bislang nicht. Der Vermittlungsausschuss von Bundestag und Bundesrat hat seine Beratung auf den 10. Dezember vertagt. Eine Stunde lang hatten Vertreter von Regierung und Opposition nach Kompromissen bei den geplanten Reformen gesucht. Beide Seiten sprachen danach von tiefgreifenden Meinungsverschiedenheiten in der Steuer- und Arbeitsmarktpolitik. Aus Protest gegen Kürzung im Bildungsetat haben Studenten die PDS-Zentrale in Berlin besetzt. Die PDS teilte mit, sie betrachte die Studenten als ihre Gäste. Für heute Mittag plant Studenten aller dreier Berliner Universitäten eine Demonstration vom Potsdamer Platz zum roten Haar draus. Die umstrittene Imbrignon-Forschung wird auch künftig nicht mit EU-Geldern gefördert. Die Forschungsminister der Europäischen Union lehnten einen entsprechenden Vorstoß der Kommission ab. Und zum Sport in der Fußball-Champions League hat der VfB Stuttgart vorzeitig das Achtelfinal erreicht. Die Stuttgarter gewannen am Abend gegen die Glasgow Rangers mit 1 zu 0. In der Basketball-Euro League hat Alba Berlin den ersten Sieg geschafft. Die Berliner bezwangen den spanischen Club Dau Vitorio mit 95 zu 89. So und jetzt mal, du hast gerade gefragt, wieviel, Max, glaube ich.
Nein, ich habe CC gesagt.
Ach so, umso schöner. Auf jeden Fall, der Verkehr hat keine Meldung. Deswegen euch eine gute Fahrt.
Jeden Samstag im Columbia Fritz Berlin. Fritz die Fete, das Original. Tanzen auf zwei Floors und chillen im kuscheligen Winterzelt. Achtung, Fritz die Fete ist nur echt mit der Super Duper Geburtstagsaktion. Und die geht so. Wer diesen Samstag oder Sonntag Geburtstag hat, feiert mit sechs Freunden umsonst. Fritz die Fete, das Original. Samstag, 23 Uhr, Columbia Fritz Berlin.
Räusper, Räusperchen, wir stören mal diese abwechslungsreiche Musik. Ja klar, jetzt wo wir was sagen, fängt der Typ auch an zu singen. Ihr hört das Chaosradio und zwar die letzte halbe Stunde, die schon gar keine mehr ist, mit im Studio der Tim vom CCC, der Jörg vom Schockwellenreiter, was seine eigene Seite ist. Also er kommt quasi von sich selber, was eine tolle Herkunft ist. Und mein Name Max und wir haben Thema heute Abend, die Bloggersphäre. Groß erklären werden wir es jetzt nicht noch mal, weil es gibt erst mal Termine zu vermelden vom Chaos Computer Club.
Genau. Vom Chaos Computer Club aber auch, was sozusagen hier unser Thema betrifft, durchaus. Ende des Jahres, sprich 27. bis 29. Dezember, das ist sozusagen zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr, immer der gleiche Termin, findet wieder statt, der Chaos Communication Kongress.
Wie meint man, 27. bis 29. Dezember ist es bei dir zwischen Weihnachten und Neujahr?
Ich mach einfach weiter, ja? Ich beachte dich nicht weiter, oder? Und ja, das ist halt so unser eingefahrener Termin, der hat Vor- und Nachteile, mehr Vorteile, wie auch immer, findet statt, diesmal nicht im Haus am Kölnischen Park, weil das gibt es nicht mehr, sondern im neu eröffneten Berliner Kongresscenter direkt am Alexanderplatz. Das ist dieses schöne Kuppelgebäude direkt neben dem Haus des Liras. Und ja, wir können nur jeden einladen, dort zu kommen, weil das wieder eine spaßige Veranstaltung werden wird, mit vielen interessanten Vorträgen, technisches Zeug, aber auch politisches Zeug, wie das eben immer die übliche Mischung ist beim CCC. Und darum hinaus gibt es auch noch ein erstes Berliner Webblogger-Meeting, was jüngst ausgerufen wurde. Okay, das magst du dann vielleicht. Du hast das ja immer so großartig in Erinnerung. Ich muss jetzt wieder meine Notizen schauen.
Also es ist bald. Es ist am 8. Dezember, Montag den 8. Dezember um 21 Uhr. Aber jetzt musst du die Pizzeria sagen.
Die habe ich vergessen.
Die heißt Duel Forni und ist in der Schönhause Allee Nr. 12.
Zwei Öfen, wenn die auch brauchen.
Wer also sozusagen die Nähe der Logosphäre sucht und sich dort warm brutzeln möchte, der kann dann sich hier direkt neben den Steinofen setzen. Ich weiß nicht, ob die einen haben, aber wir gehen erst einfach mal davon aus. Und ja, das könnte sicherlich ein lustiger Abend werden. Wer es noch etwas straighter mag, da bietet sich dann im nächsten Juli, das ist noch lange hin, aber wir wollen es trotzdem mal erwähnen, die zweite Ausgabe von dem Blogtalk, wo du ja schon darauf hingewiesen hast und auch gesagt hast, dass du beim ersten schon dabei warst. Ich habe es leider nicht geschafft, wollte eigentlich da noch hin. Du bist jetzt auch mit der Vorbereitung ein bisschen damit beschäftigt.
Momentan läuft noch nicht viel. Momentan wird an der Formulierung des Call for Papers gearbeitet. Aber es soll eben wieder ein Treffen werden, das eine Mischung ist zwischen Blogger-Treffen und auch eine Mischung zwischen vielleicht auch einer mehr oder weniger, also man muss kein Wissenschaftler sein, um daran teilzunehmen, aber mehr oder weniger einer Metabeschäftigung mit dem Thema Bloggen dann dabei. Das erste Blogger-Treffen fand ich, auch wenn es eine gewisse Ausrichtung auf die Idee vom kommerziellen Bloggen hatte oder so, fand ich trotz allem recht gemütlich und recht nett. Wir werden mal sehen, wie das zweite Blogger treffen wird. Informationen dazu wird es auf jeden Fall auch immer mal natürlich bei mir geben, www.schockwellenreiter.de, damit das auch ja keiner vergisst. www.schockwellenreiter.de, danke, dass du nachgefragt hast.
Oder auch kurz SWR.de?
Nein, SWR.de habe ich nicht. Ich denke, dass es wieder ein angenehmes und nettes Treffen sein wird. Die Konferenzsprache ist leider englisch. Das richt mich zwar immer ein bisschen auf, aber ich habe mich damit mittlerweile abgebunden.
Das finde ich natürlich eine tolle Sache. Was natürlich auch sehr wertvoll ist, darauf hinzuweisen, ist, dass während die anderen beiden angekündigten Veranstaltungen, nämlich der Kongress und das Webblogger-Meeting in Berlin stattfinden, ist das mit dem Blogtalk mitnichten so.
Das ist in Wien das Treffen.
Warum ist das so weit weg?
Das wird veranstaltet in der Hauptsache von Thomas N. Burk, und der sitzt an der Donau-Universität in Krems. Der hat sozusagen die ganze Logistik dahinter, und so ein Treffen ist ja nun nicht leicht zu organisieren. Wenn man eine Universität mit der entsprechenden Logistik dahinter hat, dann sollte man das auch ausnutzen.
Okay, 0371 77 97 110, die Nummer für heute Abend zum Thema Blogosphere. Der Termin haben wir durch, oder?
Ja, mir fallen jetzt erstmal keine ein.
Da, der Roland ist nämlich am Telefon. Hallo, Roland. Hallo. Gehst du hin am 8. Dezember?
Ja, witzigerweise bin ich ja derjenige, der das anbraucht hat.
Ja gut, dass wir dir den Termin nochmal gesagt haben.
Weil ich hab nur 30 Plätze reserviert, und es haben sich eh schon 40 Leute gemeldet. Also ich hoffe jetzt nicht, dass diese Pizzeria überrannt wird, aber wir werden ja sehen, was dann passiert.
Dann kannst du jetzt schonmal die ganze Pizzeria reservieren.
Also ich bin auf jeden Fall auf den Termin auch gespannt, weil da eben auch viele Leute kommen, von denen ich keine Ahnung habe, wer das eigentlich genau ist. Und das war eigentlich auch das, was ich ein bisschen erzählen wollte, was ein netter Effekt vom Webbloggen natürlich ist. Es sind ja, ihr habt ja schon gesagt, dass viele Webblogger selbst dann die Webblogs lesen. Die machen sicher einen großen Teil der Leser dann aus. Ein ganz anderer netter Effekt ist natürlich, dadurch, dass man in diesen Google-Ranks relativ hoch ist, können sich in diesen Kommentaren dann ganz seltsame Geschichten abspielen. Also das war halt die Geschichte, die mir dazu eingefallen ist. Also man schreibt eigentlich aus einer Laune heraus, also ich vorhin hatte es der Max ja glaube ich auch erwähnt, sozusagen halb besoffen irgendwas rein. Und dadurch einfach, dass es im Netz steht, ist es sozusagen schon Nachricht. Und dann kommen dann die Leute dahin und man setzt sich mit denen auseinander. Also das Beispiel, was ich hatte dazu war, ich hab mal was über auch eine Fernsehsendung geschrieben, über so einen Maler, Bob Ross heißt der, der so auf so komischen Kanälen wie BR Alpha, Malen nach Zahlen macht mehr oder weniger. Und auf einmal hatte ich dann ein ganzes Fanclub da drin sitzen. Also ich hab eigentlich eher darüber meinen Spot getrieben. Und der Effekt war dann, dass auf einmal ganz viele Kommentare dazu kamen. Und ich wusste gar nicht, was los ist sozusagen. Daraus dann auch dann ein eigener Fanclub tatsächlich entstanden ist.
Ein Fanclub von dir jetzt oder ein Fanclub von diesem Maler?
Nein, nicht von mir, sondern von diesem Maler halt.
Ach so, ich dachte schon.
Ich hab dann eine eigene Seite aufgemacht. Also man bekommt dann ganz seltsame Anfragen auch per Mail. Einfach weil man was geschrieben hat, ist man dann sozusagen gleich der Experte für irgendwas, obwohl das ja gar keinen Hintergrund dann hat. Das war ja ein bisschen auch eben diese Geschichte mit dem Konvent, der die vorhin erzählt wurde. Und ich hab noch einen technischen Hinweis, weil ihr ja jetzt so viel über ESS geredet habt, obwohl ich mich frage, ob das wirklich so viele Leute tatsächlich interessiert. Aber es gibt auch Bloglines, das ist auch ein Web-Service quasi, wo man seine eigenen Assets zusammenstellen kann, also praktisch ein Reader auf Web-Basis. Das würde ich dann eben empfehlen, weil vorhin auch die Frage war, was kann ich auf Linux machen, was kann ich auf Macintosh machen und so weiter. Ich weiß nun, dass es jetzt dafür über das Netz läuft, praktisch auf allen Betriebssystemen.
Ich hatte es schon mal kurz angesprochen, aber es ist durchaus noch mal wert, das noch mal kurz zu vertiefen. Das ist auf jeden Fall eine Alternative, das stimmt.
Ja, und dann sollte man natürlich auch noch die URL sagen, also www.ronsens.de, damit auch da wieder ganz viele Leute hingehen.
Vielen Dank für den Anruf. Ja, also gerade bei diesem Wer liest mich und wer mag mich, fallen mir auch noch so diese, wie du schon gesagt hast, hier hängt die Neugier-Tools ein. Webseiten, die sich ausschließlich damit beschäftigen, die Intensität und Vernetzung und Verlinkungen innerhalb der Blogosphäre nachzuvollziehen. Der erste Dienst dieser Art war, glaube ich, das webblogs.com, oder?
Ja, webblogs.com und da kam ja die Idee des Pings eigentlich. Das ist eine relativ geniale Idee, war ursprünglich war es ja immer so, dass alles lief im Prinzip auf diesem Manila Webblog-System, das war überlastet und so und dann kam ja mal die Idee, das Ganze zu dezentralisieren, aber die Information, also welches Webblog frisch abgedatet ist, welches Webblog neu ist, eben zentral zu sammeln und das war dann immer die Idee. Man schickt nur ein, wenn man abgedatet hat, schickt man ein ganz kleines winziges Datenpaket an einen zentralen Server und dieses Datenpaket weiß dann eben, aha, der Schockwellenreiter hat um 9.14 Uhr neu abgedatet und trägt das dann auf einer Webseite ein chronologisch geordnet, natürlich auch wieder. Die meisten dieser Neugier-Tools greifen heute auch noch webblogs.com ab, also die haben keinen eigenen Ping installisiert, sondern holen sich die Sachen von webblogs.com und machen dann das eben, wenn webblogs.com sozusagen die ganze Welt macht, machen die dann eben die Webblogs, die in Deutschland gemeldet sind oder irgendwie so etwas dann dabei. Es gibt auch mittlerweile schon einige, die einen eigenen Ping haben, den man also alternativ oder zusätzlich anpingen kann und die geben dann eben auch Informationen rüber. Und dann gibt es andere, die es also noch umgekehrt machen, wie eben Technorati, die dann also tatsächlich mit einer eigenen Suchmaschine die Webblogs abgrasen und danach gucken, wer was Neues hat. Und die wiederum anbieten so etwas an, wie wer verlinkt wen auch wieder. Die zeigen also, das nennen sie Cosmos, Link Cosmos. Und da sieht man dann eben halt, wenn ich dann eben halt meinen Webblog aufrufe, sieht man dann eben halt, welches Webblog auf mich gelingt hat dann dabei. Es ist mehr oder weniger zuverlässig, weil es gibt natürlich viel zu viele Webblogs dann dabei. Es werden nicht alle Links erwischt, weil es gibt Webblogs, da geht dieser Spider von Techno Ratty nie hin. Und es kommt auch meistens mit ein, zwei Tagen Verspätung. Aber es ist erstmal so etwas, um zu sehen, wer einen verlinkt hat. Und ich muss sagen, ich entdecke darüber auch dann immer wieder interessante Webblogs, die ich noch gar nicht kannte, weil die dann eben halt, die hatten dann auf mich verlinkt, die stehen dann drin, dann bin ich neugierig, gucke nach. Also wer ist das denn? Und es sind dann oft wieder interessante Webblogs, die man dann dadurch findet. Also es ist schon, schon ne schöne Sache.
Es gibt auch ne Top 100 bei Technorati. Platz 1 ist interessanterweise Slashdot. Nicht, also das einzige Webblog für sich, nicht als solches bezeichnet irgendwie, ist dann aber auch gleich Platz 1. Auf den nächsten Plätzen sind dann glaube ich im Wesentlichen diese neugierige Tools selber, also Technorati, Daypop, Blockdecks, wie sie alle heißen. Du hast ja mal, Max, mit diesem blogshares.com System rumgespielt. Ach ja, das kann man auch noch mal erzählen.
Das ist ganz nett, als es so hochgekommen ist und sich viele Leute mit diesem Thema beschäftigt haben, da ist natürlich auch der Amusementpark um das Ganze rumgezogen worden. Und Blogshares war im Grunde eine ganz einfache Sache, was auch Spaß macht für Leute, die übrigens keine Webblogs haben. Es handelt sich nämlich um so eine Art Online-Börse und es funktioniert auch wie eine Börse. Man handelt mit Aktienwerten, nur dass diese Aktienwerte eben Blogs zugeordnet sind, da kann man eben sein eigenes Webblog auch anmelden. Dann kriegt man ein bisschen Startgeld und dann fängt man an, irgendwelche Webblog-Anteile zu kaufen, wenn andere Leute die auch kaufen. Ich hab diese Prinzipien in der Börse nie verstanden, aber das war auch kackegal, weil ich hab nämlich am Anfang, als das Ding noch in der Beta-Phase war, irgendwelche Teile gekauft, von denen ich gar nicht wusste, dass sie irgendwie interessant sein könnten. Hab jetzt drei, vier Monate nicht mehr reingeguckt und bin jetzt in der Top 100 ganz, ganz oben, weil ich diese Anteile gehalten habe, die ich nie wieder angerührt habe. Das scheint also, konservatives Handeln scheint tatsächlich die beste Möglichkeit zu sein. Ich bin jetzt Multi-Milliardär und habe nichts davon.
Der erste Block-Milliardär.
Richtig. Aber es macht sehr, sehr viel Spaß, wenn man am Anfang guckt, ist mein Aktienwert, der steigt. Man kann sein eigenes Block auch da reintun. Und das ist ganz nett, weil dieses...
Was ist denn die Bewertungsgrundlage, wonach man sozusagen ein Webblock auswählt? Ob man meint, dass es populär ist oder...
Also ich muss euch sehr ganz ehrlich sagen. Du hast es nicht verstanden. Ich hab mir die Seite angeguckt. Es gibt ja den Link zur Seite. Also A, hab ich es nicht verstanden. B, hab ich mir den Link zur Seite angeguckt. War die ordentlich gemacht? C, war der Name okay? Weil es gibt ja so Seiten irgendwie kittysucksmyass, whitewhiteroomatpersianblog.com oder so und da denk ich, what the fuck, da geh ich überhaupt nicht drauf, interessiert doch keine. Ich hatte halt irgendwelche einfachen Namen genommen. lookatthis.com, wunderbar, hat immer funktioniert. Dann konntest du ja richtig Kohle mitmachen mit solchen Dingern. Weil die Menschen leben ja die einfachen Sachen. Deswegen hat da verdammt guter Kuchen auch nie gut gezogen. Das war ganz lustig zu sehen, wenn dann auch irgendwelche Aktienfuzzis bei einem vorbeigeschaut haben, die das eigene Webblog dann hochgejubelt haben und einen dann fallen gelassen haben. Wäre eine heiße Kartoffel mir heute noch traurig. Aber Spaß macht's. Also könnt ihr einfach mal vorbeigucken. www.blogshares.com Kann man auch Geld für bezahlen, wenn man will. Dann kriegt man glaube ich noch irgendwelche Extras. Seid ihr so beeindruckt von dieser Tatsache, dass es das gibt, Jungs? Der Jens aus Bonn ist noch am Telefon. Jens, hallo.
Sagen wir mal, redet der mit seiner Mutter im Hintergrund?
Nee, warte mal, warte mal, ich probiere jetzt mal die andere Seite. Ey, das System heute. Jens?
Siehst du? Notes from my terminal.
Ich habe jetzt tatsächlich rausgekriegt, was hier funktioniert und was nicht funktioniert. Geil. Jens aus Bonn, hallochen.
Hallo.
Du bist selber Webblogger, was machst du denn so?
Ja, ich habe seit ein paar Monaten einen Blog Notes from my terminal. Der Name ist, glaube ich, eben schon gefallen.
So weiß der Tim immer alles.
Ja, gefällt mir sehr gut. Weil ihr auch gefragt habt, so Erlebnisse, die man mit Bloggen gehabt hatte. Anscheinend ist sowas dann halt auch ganz häufig direkt am Anfang der Blogger-Karriere so, dass man irgendwie komische Erlebnisse hat. Ich habe irgendwie über ein Programm geschrieben, was mir ganz gut gefallen hat, aber hatte halt ein Feature, das ich vermisst habe. Hab dann geschrieben, ja, das könnte man so und so und so machen und ja, ein paar Tage später war dann der Programmierer von dem Tool, der hatte dann irgendwie einen Kommentar hinterlassen und hat gesagt, ja, das wäre ja schön, dass ich das jetzt gemacht hätte und sie hätten das jetzt irgendwie aufgenommen.
Das ist toll.
Soll ich raten, welches das ist?
Ja, rat mal.
Synkato?
Nee, das war nicht Synkato.
Ah, sondern?
Das war so ein Teil, wo man so Ideen mit organisieren konnte. Ich habe auch meinen Computer gerade nicht vor mir und habe auch irgendwie, während ich geredet habe, schon fieberhaft überlegt, wie der Name eigentlich war. Aber, ja, könnt ihr dann ja auch im Zweifelsfalle nach googeln.
Ich schau gerade mal am RSS-Rider. Aber ist schon eine Weile her, ne?
Ja, ist schon eine Weile her. War irgendwie ganz am Anfang und so. Noch eine Sache irgendwie zu dieser ganzen Geschichte, irgendwie Blogs und was sie auslösen können. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr irgendwie... Leider habe ich die Sendung nicht ganz verfolgen können, aus technischen Gründen, die ich hier nicht weiter ausbreiten möchte. Habt ihr das Thema Flashmobs schon erwähnt?
Nein.
Ja, war ja irgendwie so der Hype des letzten Sommers, ne? Das stimmt. Also kam aus dieser Ecke von Howard Reingold und so weiter. Und die Idee dahinter war eigentlich, dass man so eine Art Adhokratie oder so was macht. Also man verabredet sich spontan und verändert dann die Geschichte und so. Und von Künstlern ist das dann irgendwie auch dann aufgegriffen worden. Die haben dann irgendwie über Webblogs, über E-Mails oder so sich verabredet und haben dann absurde Aktionen irgendwie in der New Yorker Innenstadt gemacht, um die Realität ab einem bestimmten Punkt zu brechen. Das Ganze ist dann halt irgendwie weltweit auch verbreitet worden. Und als es dann irgendwie so weit verbreitet war, dass es nach Deutschland kam, hat es dann mittlerweile auch schon den Status erreicht, dass es irgendwie so, naja, es war so auf dem Niveau von Schatzen, die irgendwie Kegelklubs oder sowas machen. Also es hatte dann schon doch ein bisschen an Niveau verloren. Aber war auf jeden Fall irgendwie im letzten Sommer so eine der Sachen, wo man ja auch gemerkt hat, wie Webblogs und Realität interagieren.
Hat, glaube ich, auch in Berlin mal funktioniert, ne? Da gab es doch einen. Sogar mit einer ganz lustigen Einmengung. Ich weiß nicht mehr genau, was das war.
Ja, es war irgendwie was Kommerzielles, was dabei war. Ich habe es aber auch vergessen. Irgendwie so Burger King hat aufgerufen, dass sich alle am Potsdamer Platz treffen oder so. Aber irgendwie habe ich jetzt auch nicht mehr im Kopf, was es genau war.
Ich glaube, das war ein Treffen am Alex.
Nein, das war auch nicht Burger King. Ich meinte jetzt nur, es war irgendwas mit Veranstalter, aber irgendwas Kommerzielles dann dabei.
Ja, die Flashmops. Das hat zumindest gezeigt, dass Webblogs in der Lage sind, auch sehr kurzfristig eine relativ große Zahl von Leuten zu schrägen Dingen zu bewegen. Also noch sehr viel wichtiger, als dass es irgendwie schräge Sachen sind, finde ich, dass es überhaupt so eine Kurzfristigkeit hat. Weil ich glaube, diese Flashmops wurden dann auch binnen, ich weiß nicht, hast du das in Erinnerung? Stunden? Einen Tag?
Naja, genau. Also das ist halt eine ganz kurze Geschichte und wird am Tag davor angekündigt und ist eine Sache von 5 Minuten dann eigentlich auch gewesen. Weitergeführt wird das Ganze halt irgendwie auch noch von vielen anderen Denkern im Internet. Den Namen Joey Ito müsste man eigentlich auch nochmal erwähnen, wenn es um Webblogs geht. Das ist so ein Typ, der Venture Kapitalist ist aus Japan, sich schon sehr, sehr lange mit dem Internet beschäftigt und auch damit beschäftigt, was das Internet denn Positives für die Gesellschaft zu bieten hat. Und der hat auch einige Ideen zum Thema Demokratie, Verbesserung über Internet, über Webblogs etc. Also was mir an den Webblogs sehr gut gefällt, wahrscheinlich sogar an den englischsprachigen Webblogs eher als an den deutschsprachigen, dass man da halt auch eine Menge schlauer Leute findet, die schlaue Sachen irgendwie von sich geben. Und dass das irgendwie auch ein bisschen dem Rest der Technik-Sphäre sehr weit voraus ist. Also wenn man lange Webblogs liest, dann kommt man irgendwann auf die Idee, dass alle relevanten Leute sowieso einen Macintosh benutzen, was ja in der anderen Realität, in der wir leben, ja nicht so ganz der Fall ist.
Das habe ich auch schon mehrfach feststellen dürfen.
Also oder auch was die Anwendung von Standards, also irgendwie XHTML 1.1 oder so was, also wirklich so, dass die blutige, gerade neue Release des Standards oder so, die werden sofort von den Webbloggern übernommen. Die sind halt dann auch geil, solche neuen Technologien wie RSS oder so was einzusetzen. Während der Rest der Userschaft erst mal wartet und sagt, ja gut, im Jahr hat sich das dann vielleicht durchgesetzt und dann übernehmen wir das auch. Also man kann durch Webblogs auch so ein bisschen Blick in die Zukunft wagen.
Das ist doch ein schönes Schlusswort, weil wir sind nämlich auch am Ende der Sendung, Jens. Man kann einen Blick in die Zukunft wagen. Das nehmen wir einfach so mit. Gruß nach Bonn.
Ja, Gruß nach Berlin. Gruß nach Düsseldorf dann auf dem Heft wieder.
So, das war's mit dem Chaosradio für den heutigen Abend. Geht gleich weiter mit dem Night Flight und Martin Petersdorf. War wunderschön, das hat sehr viel Spaß gemacht. Wir haben uns den Mundfusselig geredet und ihr auch. Tim Brittlauwe. Warum eigentlich jetzt Brittlauwe? Ich hab dich so oft Brittlauwe genannt.
Ja, ich hab mich schon immer gewundert.
Ach so. Ach, Carsten, weißt du, Claudio. Das find ich einfach, Tim.
Ja, verdammt guter Kuchen, nicht wahr? Wir lesen uns dann auch wieder.
Versucht's einfach mal, Berlin und Brandenburg, schaut euch ein bisschen um. Ach so, zwei Sachen will ich noch korrigieren. bloghouse.net, nicht DE, bloghouse, da gibt's ein paar Infos. bloghouse.net Und es gibt einen Blog zum Thema Studentenproteste unter http://protest.blogger.de Also wenn ihr was darüber lesen wollt, das wurde gerade empfohlen bei uns auf der Seite.
Ich hab auch noch einen Wunsch, und zwar um mal dieses Trackback noch mal auszuprobieren. Ich hab ja in meinem Webblog tim.geekheim.de ich glaube ich der einzige, der hier noch keine Url hat fallen lassen, auch einen Eintrag sozusagen als Ankündigung für diese Seite. Wenn ihr jetzt während der Sendung schon was geschrieben habt, würde ich mich sozusagen sehr freuen, da den Trackback auch einzusammeln, in dem auf diesen Eintrag gelinkt wird, welches jetzt meiner Letzter ist, um das auch gleich mal ein bisschen nachrecherchieren zu können, was jetzt die Auswirkung gewesen ist.
Ja, dem würde ich mich auch gerne anschließen. Ich habe auch einen solchen Eintrag und ich habe jetzt auch einen Trackback. Der Eintrag ist heute bei mir auch mit einem schönen Foto vom Sony Center im Potsdamer Platz. Also da dürft ihr jetzt auch ganz furchtbar drauf Trackbacken, damit ich weiß, wer über diese Sendung berichtet hat.
Und du hast ja auch...
Ich hab ja auch Trackback und deswegen möchte ich, dass ihr auch bei mir Trackbackt. Weil natürlich auch die Frage jetzt schon in Board gekommen ist, wo kommen denn die ganzen Links nochmal hin, wenn ihr irgendwelche Links gesammelt habt oder ihr habt noch irgendwelche Hinweise, einfach in die Kommentare posten, weil dann können wir auf dem Fritzball einfach einen Link auf unsere Webblogs machen und alle, die noch Fragen haben und nicht wissen, wo finden, weil so eine Sendung ist ja lang und vieles gefallen, dann kann man das da alles nochmal nachlesen. Dann müssen wir das nämlich nicht chronistenpflichtig chronistenmäßig aufschreiben. Vielen, vielen Dank auch fürs Hiersein an dich, Jörg. War schön, dass du hier warst. Shopwellenreiter.de ist auf jeden Fall die Adresse, die ihr besuchen solltet. Und wir müssen dem Martin Petersdorf jetzt leider das Feld räumen. Wir könnten noch stundenlang weiter reden. Ich habe für den Schluss ein Lied mitgebracht. Darf ich das spielen? Ich weiß, du hast jetzt die ganze Zeit Musik beigesteuert. Zwar habe ich es heute erst entdeckt. A Persian Voodoo von Christian Morgenstern, ein Brett. Viel Spaß. Bis zum nächsten Chaosradio am letzten Mittwoch im Monat.
Nicht im Dezember, aber im Januar dann wieder.
Genau. Da ist nämlich frei. Obwohl, vielleicht kriegen wir eins hin. Mal gucken.
Ja, vielleicht mal gucken.
Okay, und jetzt kommt das Brett.
Macht's gut.